Hello everybody!
Okay, look it was not my fault.
I was late this time.
Okay, I was ready.
I was so ready But the reason why I was a little bit late today is because the game wasn't downloadable until launch day And then even then, even then they didn't put it up They didn't put up the download button until five to six minutes later.
So it is not my fault
This time, this time I take zero responsibility Okay guys, I might have taken responsibility like in the past But I know for this one time I do not take responsibility for being late It was not my fault!
Okay, at one point I almost let the intrusive thoughts win and like because I was like Where download button?
Where download button?
And I was like on Twitch I was like Did anyone else got the download button on Twitch?
Because I was like seeing like oh maybe some some Twitch Weimer So I got the download button and then I saw like Bandai was doing an official launch stream of Sandland where they were like, you know hyping up Sandland and I almost I almost typed in chat Where download button?
I was gonna be one of those people Because they're like, oh, I hope you guys are happy because I was watching it because I was like watching us like oh, maybe don't know Don't tell us if there's a delay and Then and then they were like we hope you enjoyed Sandland.
Yeah.
Oh, it's up.
We hope you enjoy it It's up now guys go and download Sandland for the official launch like on that official stream and I was gonna I was like I was typing us ready I was like We're down though I almost was like we're down though I almost I almost did it but I didn't let the intrusive thoughts win this time.
I didn't become a Karen.
I was like, okay.
I'll wait
I'll wait a little bit but also because the moment I was about to type it The download button showed up so I was saved by the download button.
I was saved by the download button actually showing up so I didn't embarrass myself today.
I didn't embarrass myself in front of the poor PR people at Bandai.
Because I think they were also like, oh no where is the download button?
So I didn't use it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Play Sandstorm by the dude.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, for those who don't know this game.
This is Sandland.
It is a game that's based off the manga slash anime from Akira Toriyama.
And obviously this is like one of the first games that are released, you know, post... what's the word?
Post-hum...
I can't pronounce it but you know...
Salute to Akira Toriyama.
But this was the first game to be released afterwards.
And you know, I've been super hyped to check it out.
And I'm looking forward to it.
Apparently I was like...
I was like...
Sort of like hesitant on trying this out because I saw it was like RPG.
But then I read that it was like action RPG.
So I was like, I like action.
Maybe the action will balance out the RPG elements.
Maybe... I was like...
Maybe the action part will balance that out.
And because like I'm not like a super...
Because I don't really have that much of an attention span for like RPGs and stuff.
RPGs are good.
Look, it is called preferences.
And...
And like...
I do not have the attention span for RPGs.
Especially like JRPGs.
Because like I have such a low attention span when it comes to like reading.
That...
That lore goes from one ear to the other and then it disappears.
And then I would be playing the RPG part and I'd be like, what the fuck is going on?
I'd be like...
I'd be like, who's this guy again?
Wait, what's the character...
Who am I playing as?
What is her story?
I don't know.
And then what I use...
Okay, this is...
Here's a little tidbit about me that will make you understand it more.
So in Pokemon games, when you select moves, I make sure all my Pokemon moves are just straight on full attack.
I don't care about stats or anything.
Like...
Like things that will get rid of stats and all that stuff.
I just want...
I see the PP move and I was like, ooh, it does more damage.
Okay, all four of my moves are ultimate damage.
And so like...
You see that for Pokemon, that's four moves.
Now imagine like I play a JRPG slash RPG and it's all my moves.
I'd be like, okay, all my moves just do damage in all my 20 moves that I have in this JRPG.
That's all I know.
And then if I am low, okay, do I have any heals?
Oh, I don't because I put all my...
I put all my skills in just damage.
Oh, okay.
So...
That is why.
Like for me, I know that...
I know that like the RPG and JRPG stuff, like I know for me is definitely not my strongest suit.
So I was like, okay, maybe the...
I saw I was watching the gameplay of it and I was like, oh, okay.
I see a lot of open world action in there.
I was like, oh, all right.
I can work with that.
I can work with the open world action.
I can work with the open world part.
And I was like, oh, tanks.
I can work with that.
I can work with the tanks too.
And I was like, all right, this is good.
This is good.
This is it.
I'm going to...
I'm going to try this out.
And then if you never see a part two of this game, then you know why.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Every time you talk about reading, you further prove the stereotype that both dragoons and you can't read.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Here you go.
Oh, I mean, it seems all right.
I think.
All right.
Press any key.
Is my sound guy here today?
Is my sound guy here?
Oh, oh, my God.
By the way, I pre-ordered the deluxe version because I was like, I want to be special.
I want to pay to win.
A game that I don't know if we're going to get a part two on.
I was like, I don't know if I'm going to get part two.
But, ooh, more items.
That means more items that can affect my gameplay.
Let's fucking go.
120 FPS limit.
And then that's good.
You don't...
Yes, save these settings.
Okay.
Obviously, voice has to always be up.
I feel like.
Just up the voice.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't know if sound guy is here.
So today, in one of those rare moments, we're going to let the chat...
Wait, are any of my mods here?
Oh, no.
No.
This might be...
This might get a little rowdy.
I'll increase it a bit later.
Without it.
Oh, no.
What's that word call when we have actual...
When we have no leaders in place?
Oh, no.
Not the chaos.
Anarchy.
Oh, no.
It's going to be an anarchy now.
There's no...
None of the mods are here.
Casually enjoy.
Okay, I'm not gonna do hard... I don't know what this game is gonna be like.
Guys, I'm gonna do normal.
I don't have any... if it was an FPS game with like zero...
uh... resource... with like zero like... like what was it?
Scarce resource shit?
Then it would be fine.
Who needs mod when there is... oh... oh... oh...
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You think that.
But then when you become a real... when you become an actual streamer...
then... then you realize... having mods might... might not be a very... might not be a bad idea.
Cause giving chat too much power... is... is a little stupid.
If chat has too much power, it'll just be Twitch... it'll just be a YouTube play sand land.
Oh my god!
Mods here!
Guys... guys... our mods... okay.
Alright.
Other silent.
You're... you're gonna be my designated sound guy.
I know you have zero like... um... experience with sound.
But I trust you.
Today you're gonna learn.
You're gonna learn to be the new sound guy.
My substitute sound guy.
Scattery.
Alright.
I'm a little worried that this is taking a long time to save.
Oh wait.
Oh!
It's telling me.
I thought... I thought it was saving my game!
I was like...
Why is this taking so long to save?
I was like... damn.
Oh!
Look, it's a little ghost.
I love his style.
It's so recognizable.
I love that he just really loves to draw vehicles too.
I feel like...
He became a manga artist just to draw sick ass vehicles.
Oh my god!
Sound guy's here!
JK... JK other mod.
You're fired and rehired to be like regular mod now.
The actual...
No benefits by the way.
No overtime.
No... uh...
No...
No firing package by the way.
No... no firing package by the way.
What the fuck?
I never read or watched the manga anime of Sadland.
So this is zero context for me.
I think that's called a deep motion.
Shit.
What happens if I lose him?
Bro there's no way I can lose him.
There's no way I can go.
I can't even run off into the distance.
I can't even run off into the distance bro.
Yeah no severance pay by the way.
Okay that guy's just a centaur.
I can't believe he grouped up the centaur.
With an actual...
Oh shit!
I'm sorry.
I was trying to be a streamer.
Alright here we go.
Yay!
Okay not gonna lie.
Alright this is a little bit of a nitpicky.
But like I hate the subtitle font.
The subtitle font is pretty bad.
Oh my god!
They're in the middle of nowhere.
Thanks for the water.
You're just gonna leave them to die?
You're a demon.
Demons don't need water.
I mean he's a fucking demon.
How are they gonna drive back?
This is why I'm being jerked.
I'm in the desert or jungle.
This is exactly why I'm like...
Being stuck in the middle of the desert.
There's no water.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Do I have to wait for their moves?
Oh I was gonna say...
Powerful.
Wait bullets don't work on me anyway.
Right?
Shoot me.
Come on!
Shoot me!
Yeah it does nothing.
There's no sense of...
There's no sense of like...
Actual urgency.
That's my chance?
What?
Oh epic attack.
There you go.
Get over here.
I'm gonna beat you up too.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Come on.
Stop running away.
Get over here.
You can't run away from me.
You're full HP already but I beat the shit out of you.
Get over here.
Come on.
Stop running away.
Alright.
Boop.
Nice.
And they forever disappeared.
They vanished.
Back into the sand you go.
The nature...
The nature of...
I think I can absorb them.
Okay.
Who the fuck...
His name is Grumman.
There's a little ferret kid too.
Alright.
Let's boost up the volume a little bit.
Oh wait.
I can actually boost up the volume within the in-game settings.
What am I doing?
Alright.
Which...
I like how if I don't press anything it just be like, oh my god.
I have a couple seconds of silence.
We're only taking a bit.
We leave them to a little bit.
I just took everything.
Then I just took all his fucking water.
Oh, it's like Mad Max.
It's like Japan Mad Max.
Cause like...
He has all the water.
Alright, let me...
Guys, apparently you can't go to the menu.
You can't go to the menu while you're talking.
It's Anime Australia.
Exactly.
Make that kid pay.
Yeah, but what if she drinks all the water after that?
He's still gonna die.
You didn't solve anything.
If we're gonna start doing good deeds, we might as well turn in our pitchforks.
Shut it.
I'll torment the kid plenty once he grows up.
If he's gonna grow up.
You're just delaying it.
He'll die regardless.
He still has no source of water.
Joshua, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Why is young Majin Buu cruising around with a trolley?
Doki, I don't think Mad Max has the wrong center.
That's right.
It's a better version of Mad Max.
This guy.
Oh, this is a different centaur.
Who's he?
Wait, who's dying?
Who the fuck is slime?
I think he accidentally fell asleep in the sun again.
Maddy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mad Max if it was good.
Just because it's anime.
It doesn't mean it's better than the original.
Nothing's ever easy.
It's like.
Okay, to be fair.
The anime bible is sort of better than the regular bible.
Okay, this is my opinion.
Okay guys, so in case I get canceled or anything.
Just remember this was my opinion.
But I think anime Jesus is a bit better than regular Jesus.
I am tied up with other tasks though.
Huh.
Fine.
You don't know anime Jesus?
The bible actually has a manga slash anime based off of it.
Alright, after accepting a new quest.
A quest icon will appear on the map.
To show where you should go to progress the quest.
Oh yeah, sound guy.
Should I increase the overall volume including voice?
Or is it just like some parts of the game?
I'll divvy it up then.
Cause there's like.
Uh.
Oh, I can dash.
Okay, oh thank god.
I can run faster.
Cause.
We have.
We have multiple.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay.
Oh yeah.
This is like first day launch stuff.
Okay.
Okay guys.
We realize.
Guys, we realize.
What launch day is gonna be like.
Oh.
Maybe it's just this place.
You know.
Maybe.
Oh okay.
We have to read this.
Why does he have a voice?
Okay.
He has a voice.
Everybody else.
Fuck the other guys I guess.
Fuck that one centaur in general.
Okay.
Let's see.
I have to go this way.
I wonder how many of these NPCs are just one guy.
Doing like ten voices.
Raptor scales?
Oh, it's not even a.
A regular side quest.
Hey.
You okay?
Here.
Have some water.
For free?
What kind of fucking demon are you?
Want a toe down?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Using that logic.
Does that mean non-AnimeDokiBird is better than AnimeDokiBird?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're a demon!
You can't die from dehydration?
Oh, I get stuff?
Oh my god.
I got something in return.
I got B grade steel.
Nice.
Alright, at least... I guess helping people is good sometimes.
I guess sometime it's good.
Oh, I just like walked away from him.
Was I supposed to help him?
I like that I was supposed to talk to him.
I was like, alright, anyway.
And the game was like, wait, come back.
Wait, did you forgot this one kid?
And it's a tie.
Here you go.
Here's some water.
I guess.
I'm running out.
It's just a side character.
Leave him.
By the way, raise up the volume.
Let me know if it's better.
Sound guy.
Yeah, you know what?
Fuck the humans.
If we let more humans die, there's more chances for them to become demons.
So smart.
Alright, we go.
We gotta go talk to the slime.
Cause apparently he's also dying.
I can double jump now.
Ooh.
Hello.
Is that him?
Oh, I thought I could step on him.
Hello.
Oh, I think I'm on the wrong side.
Who's there?
Hello.
I don't think he looks okay.
But if he's the slime king and I'm the prince demon...
It would be a shame...
Okay, it would be a shame if I don't do it in time.
Wait, actually...
It would be such a shame if I...
If we ran out of time.
Oh no!
Long live the king!
God, what a waste of water!
Also, how much water is in this bottle?
Thomas, thank you for your favorite super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
And my dokey bird JoJo's tense tomato.
I'm gonna go get some water.
Oh my water!
I'm alive again!
This is the king?
Oh, thought you were a goner!
Uh-huh, great.
Why is your voice so dang loud?
Yeah!
Quest complete!
Stop falling asleep in the sun, would ya?
He's just a regular guy?
I thought they said slime king!
I'm a real scorcher!
He's just a regular slime?!
I wasted all my water on this one slime?!
The name is always...
Should've been survival of the fittest.
If he was dumb enough to get like melted by the sun, he did not deserve to live.
Why'd the world have to end up like this?
We need to have powerful slimes.
Things have been like this for around 50 years now.
Ever since man's foolishness...
and a succession of natural disasters...
To be a kind ruler, what's that?
...to extend farther and farther...
until it had swallowed up the entire world.
What does that mean?
I thought I bring up the volume a little bit more already.
I just brought up the volume.
...who somehow managed to survive.
Well, they just kept on waging their pointless wars.
You're in position!
Oh wait, what?
The war is just ahead!
We have received word that the P.G.
have died in time!
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh no, I didn't realize the ammo's limited.
Nice.
Annihilate the enemy!
No, I missed!
Protect the P.G.!
Okay, got it.
We can't let them destroy that machine.
Guard it at all costs!
World of tanks time!
Anime world of tanks!
Just like anime mad mad.
Max!
Why do I do my nitro?
Like this?
What am I supposed to do?
Boom?
Oh!
That's it?
Just one shot?
Yeah, Toria, I'mma love the vehicles.
And so...
That woman?
The humanity's inane belligerence resulted...
Oh no, that's the helmet.
I thought that was hair.
...in the worst possible outcome for the entire planet.
Just cause of one stupid mistake, man.
I wish somebody would have make a compilation of like all his like vehicle art.
Or vehicle designs.
They're all the same.
I feel so creative too.
In some alternate universe, instead of Teslas, we would have Toriyama vehicles.
Why?
Man, I wonder why.
Man,
I wonder why.
This encounter is about to change this dying wasteland forever.
Oh my god, it's the iconic!
It's the iconic Toriyama car!
Or bike!
Girl.
Sandalaboma!
A human.
Mr. Earthworm!
Hercules!
That's right, I'm a human.
I come from a neighboring town.
But like, what if he just has no muscles?
I'm here to help.
Because I want to ask for you demons' help.
Now, is one of your leaders willing to listen to what I have to say?
Oh my god, Mr. Satan!
I don't know why I said Mr. Hercules.
He even has an S for a badge!
I see him as Hercules instead of Satan.
So, are you the demon's leader?
That's me!
The great king Lucifer is our leader.
But...
Oh, that's my dad!
Hercules was his Christian name.
I'm the fiend prince Beelzebub.
Oh, his English name is Hercules!
I knew it!
I was like, oh my god, did I actually fucked up?
I watched Dragon Ball Z so much.
How did I confuse Hercules and Satan?
I was like...
Okay, I might not have recently watched Dragon Ball.
But I grew up with that.
How the fuck did I mess that up?
I like your assistance with my mission.
Searching for the legendary spring.
The legendary spring?
Explain.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, love the content.
It's not a problem.
Would you mind wishing my friend Giggles a happy birthday?
It would mean a lot to her.
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Giggles.
Yeah!
You must have sun stroke or something.
Whoops.
Sorry.
A water finch?
It's still alive?
It still exists?
Because I saw a water finch flying north yesterday.
Oh my god, that means there's water!
This means there must be a spring with small fish to sustain these birds.
Somewhere in this desert...
There must not be a lot though.
Because it's just one pool of water.
But the desert to the south of here is dangerous and wild.
I doubt a lone human could make it even so far as half a mile away.
That's why I'm here.
I would like for a powerful demon to accompany me on my journey.
Let's say we somehow manage to find this spring.
Yeah but what if we like end up like eating all the fish in the spring?
Because like humans or demons are greedy motherfuckers.
And because of that and then the birds will die.
And then we're gonna ruin the ecosystem!
And then we're gonna have another global warming!
Between them?
Yeah, 2x2 water pod.
Bro, like it's a fucking spring, not a lake.
There's a king too?
You guys have a king as well?
I don't think the world can get any warmer, Doki.
We must find this spring by ourselves for the people.
Doesn't sound like a bad deal.
But we've been doing fine stealing water for ourselves.
Yeah, why don't we trick him to tell us where the spring is and then kill him?
What the fuck is that?
Like a playstation?
Does that need electricity which needs water?
Oh my god, bro, he gave me a playstation.
Pills, thank you for the 10, get the shits, thank you.
Don't I need water to run electricity?
Like what?
I'll ask my dad for permission.
Is that- that's a Saturn?
It looks like a playstation 1 to me.
I never had a Sega Saturn.
I thought it was a playstation 1 but like what if it's black?
What if it was like copyright free playstation 1?
I mean, he brought us a game console.
How are we guys- how are we gonna play this game?
But what if he's got the- How are we gonna plug in the Sega Saturn?
I don't know if he means us harm.
And if he does, I'll kick him into next week.
There's still wind power.
Does this look like we have wind?
Solar power.
Dude, does this look like we live in a place that has electricity, guys?
Join what?
I like how so- I like how this guy has- has voice acting.
Oh, heard about the Peachy, Prince?
Uh, yeah.
Peachy?
That rings a bell.
Who's that?
Their aliens supposedly came to Earth about 70 years ago.
And shared their super advanced tech with humans.
I hear they've all been wiped out by this point though.
Guys, if we had electricity, we would not be using fire as our light source.
If we have solar power.
Because goddamn, we have so much solar.
Like...
Okay, it's...
Where is it?
Is it...
I assume it's here because there's guards.
I hear ya.
Magic maybe?
I've yet to see anything that's powered by energy, guys.
Maybe it's the aesthetic.
Fire saves electricity.
Doki, you don't understand.
But we got tanks and cars.
We don't know if the demons have tanks and cars.
We just saw the humans.
Hey, Dad.
Oh, what?
That's that guy in Dragon- I think I was like, everything from Dragon Ball Z.
Yes.
I heard.
Aide him.
Let humans' plan will benefit us as well.
The Buddha!
And he seems trustworthy enough.
And it gives you a chance to sharpen your skills.
Y-Yes, sir!
That said...
Once you return, you're only allowed to use that console for a while.
One hour?
I'm already only 20 minutes away from one hour!
Be sure to only play in a bright room.
That's like half a tutorial in Kingdom Hearts!
Not even half.
That's like one fourth of a tutorial.
That's like 20% of the tutorial in Kingdom Hearts.
It's weird.
Booo!
We're going in this?
How many passengers can fit?
With luggage?
Well, can we fit our centaur?
Two?
Then, me...
Centaur.
He's- Look at him!
He has abs!
Thief, I guess.
What?
Why me?
He's old!
Centaur has abs!
Look at him!
You're good at stealing!
Bro, he doesn't even get the car!
Just run behind us!
Grinch, I just thought of something.
Wouldn't it be easier to have someone who can fly carry you there?
Quit complaining and get your butt in here right now!
No, it's cause he's strong!
Like, we...
Bro, he can just run after us with his horse legs!
Head to the legendary spring.
Believe in the old guy.
Two old men instead one.
Why?
Imbalance.
Too many old men.
Please pick support.
How long do you think this is gonna take?
Call me Raul, please.
Raul.
And, well, probably quite some time.
Hey, let me take the wheel for a bit.
Leave the human machines to their makers, ladies.
Sure, take it for a spin.
For real?
Oh my god, I'm gonna learn how to drive!
I'm gonna get my first driving lesson!
Oh, I'm gonna get my first driving lesson!
Can he, like, touch the pedals?
Like, he's so short!
Alright.
Autopilot.
Oh my god, thank god.
Alright.
Boost.
Brake.
Fast travel to towns or camps where you've already been in the map menu.
Move the cursor or desire to hold X and X to travel there.
Fast travel might be disabled.
Okay.
Uh, let's see.
Why to leave vehicle.
Uh, move autopilot.
Boost.
Brake.
Okay.
First time driving.
Alright, that's the autopilot.
Can you guys tell?
JK, that was actually me.
That was actually me.
I tricked you guys.
JK, that was actually autopilot.
Hahaha!
Oh, I can boost in autopilot!
Can I, like...
Get rid of... Okay, I can get rid of autopilot if I...
Wait, what happens if I go, like...
Oh.
Okay.
So, I don't...
Oh, guys!
Guys!
Did you see that?
I drove off the cliff and it took me closer to the destination!
It's the secret!
It's the secret guys!
Okay, no, JK.
JK, I was just next to it.
You have HP?
Where?
There's no HP.
Oh my god, I can drift!
Look at that!
I'm drifting!
Am I drifting?
I can't tell.
Alright.
There you go.
We're doing it.
Speedrun strat.
Wait, what's that over there?
There's something over here!
Wait, I gotta take a break here.
There's stuff there!
Did you guys see that?
Look!
What's over here?
There has to be stuff in this cave, right?
Oh my god, look at all this loot!
Oh, I can't punch a scorpion.
9 out of 10 can't punch scorpions.
Oh my god, I already got loot.
Guys.
Look at all this loot that I got.
Nice.
Alright.
We gotta go back.
Vegetable oil?
Oh my god, I can cook now too.
I got vegetable oil.
Alright.
Woah, what's that?!
Get out!
Wait, did you guys see that?
Oh my god, what is that?!
Oh, I'm already out!
Okay, now it's a 10 out of 10 game again.
Now it's a 10 out of 10.
I'm gonna run over the babies first.
Okay, now it's a 10 out of 10 game again.
That's right.
Oh my god, it's switching!
Don't worry, I need to double tap.
There we go.
Alright, let's leave.
I get one experience for that!
That's so fucked up.
Alright, there we go.
Let's leave now.
No!
I overheated!
Oh, is that more babies?
Oh, she's not adopted.
Look, see!
I introduced a mom to new babies that she can adopt!
I realized there were...
Guys, no, you don't understand.
You don't understand, guys.
I saw the babies up there with no mom.
So, obviously, I had to make sure they get adopted.
So, I found a mom that had babies.
And then I killed those babies so the mom can adopt the new babies.
And then we solved the all...
Orphan problem.
I'm a hero.
I gave those babies a mom!
Woah,
what the fuck?
I literally ran over some babies.
What do you mean?
Okay.
The Genji dragon will chase after your car.
It buries deep under the earth.
Oh, we're Dune now.
Anime Dune time.
Clear it to you, then use to dodge left and right.
Okay, I just need to dodge.
This is 10.
Oooh.
He wouldn't know where I'm going if I just go left and right.
There's no way.
He wouldn't know where I'm going if I just...
If I'm just left and right all the time.
Oh shit, did I miss?
How?
Oh god, oh god.
Okay, maybe...
Woo!
I'm going as fast...
What?
How am I supposed to dodge that?
I'm trying!
I don't know how he knows!
Every time!
Maybe stop zigzagging.
No, I don't know man.
Guys, I don't know.
Oh, I did it!
Guys, I should stop zigzagging.
I just figured it out.
I'm trying!
It won't let me boost!
Oh my god!
It doesn't let me boost!
I can just drive!
Oh my god!
I'm driving as fast as I can, bro.
Grandpa, I'm literally driving as fast as I can.
No!
Armaterius!
Turn around!
He's already dead!
Turn around and get our shit back!
Turn around
and get our shit back!
That was our one month supplies that we just lost.
He just barely escaped!
We're barely outside the village.
And we've lost all our food and water.
We lost all our food and water!
We...
Well, I guess we lost all of it.
We lost all of it.
So, what should we do?
Without provisions, surely our only choice is to turn back.
Yeah, how the fuck are we to survive without food or water?
I knew I should have looted those babies.
You know, there should be a town called Talbo not too far from here.
Not that I have any money, but we'll figure something out.
We don't have money?
You're a sheriff!
Fine then.
He's broke!
Let's get rid of him.
What do you mean?
We don't have money!
Alright, we'll probably get back to the car.
I'm a child!
Please, try to leave!
Oh, what's this?
There's a duck here.
Oh, a new treasure!
What is that?
Ah, shucks.
It's just a toy duck.
It's got balls.
It has bite marks too.
They must have been so hungry.
They'd even eat a toy.
Oh no!
That's no laughing matter.
Those poor children!
There's no military food relief here.
And bandits are rampant.
It's no wonder the people would starve.
My god.
Rumor has it that starvation drove them to eat horrible food.
Cannibals!
Horrible?
Like what?
Like their own fucking kind.
Prince, some things are better left unsaid.
Why?
Because we're talking about humans doing something.
Something that is taboo, even to us.
Cannibalism?
Is cannibalism our line?
Oh, not murder.
Hold on.
It's not murder, but cannibalism is our line here.
And yet...
They must have been in dire straits to come so close to breaking that taboo.
So you're saying this toy like symbolizes a taboo.
That's kinda cool.
I'll keep it.
Cannibalism.
Bad.
Murder?
Okay.
Nice, I got a toy.
Wait, there's people here.
Where are all the people?
Oh, there's no people there.
Wait, is he bad?
So why did they all leave?
Are you bad?
I'd like to move somewhere safer.
It's dangerous around here.
There's people here.
There's Riku.
Okay, you don't have to yell.
And you what?
See, I was headed for Talbo.
But I couldn't find the Arch landmark and got hopelessly lost.
I thought I was a goner until I came across a traveling merchant in this ghost town.
But now I know I'm a goner.
Why'd I have to run into demons of all things?
It must be my destiny to die here.
For such a fraidy cat, he sure can talk.
Cool it.
We're not gonna kill you.
Just go.
Really?
Thanks!
Not until you give me shit.
I'm just gonna let him go?
I'm just gonna let this man go?
That's it?
That's his entire plot?
Oh hey, there's a... there's a traveler.
Can I beat up this dinosaur?
Oh, I can't.
Who is he?
Is he a merchant in this world?
Please!
I'm begging you!
Just don't steal my soul!
Anything but that!
I can't steal souls.
And even if I could, why would I want to?
What is my purpose?
As a demon, what can I do?
How am I different from a regular person?
You sure changed his tune quickly.
Louder voices?
Okay, I'll...
What are you doing here?
Up the voices, guys.
Hey.
Oh, I'm just a humble peddler, traveling all over this kingdom to sell my wares.
Now lower the sound.
I'm running low on inventory, so I'm heading back home.
I have a tail.
So you don't live here?
Alright.
Of course not.
This village was abandoned.
Why is that?
Well, this and that happened, and the residents... went away.
How about being less vague?
This whole village was built from the ground up during the old war, to create a safe place to send civilian evacuees.
The old war?
Oh, the one with the tanks?
So did the royal army supply shipments.
That cut down the population lickety-split.
And as if that was...
Oh, it's the old war.
It's like survival of the fittest.
...started raiding the place once the army pulled out of the area.
What you see before you is the result.
You'd better watch out for bandits yourselves.
Heh.
Like petty thieves are gonna...
Can I run over the bandits?
Well, you never can be too careful.
You know what they say.
An ounce of prevention's worth a pound of cure.
On that note, check out my wares!
They're sure to come in handy on your travels.
What do you have for sale?
Okay, before that, I'm gonna like...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Guys, we're never gonna look at the menu.
Okay, okay.
Guys, okay, we're gonna...
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm gonna...
Guys, this just launched, guys.
Okay?
Guys, let me...
Guys, okay.
This game...
This game just launched, okay?
Please, please be kind.
Okay, I'm gonna lower the BGM and...
And the effects so we can up the...
So we can up the overall sound with the game volume.
Okay, let's see.
I upped the voice volume to 100.
And then I'm gonna up the...
I'm gonna up the sound a little bit too.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, we're just never gonna look at the menu.
What can I buy?
Strength Serum?
And I can sell stuff too.
Oh, I can sell the Raptor Scale!
Oh, it has the Strength of Metals?
Okay.
Sending your hospital bills...
Sending your hospital bills to Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe humans actually managed to live here until recently.
How's the volume now, guys?
There's no place like home.
That means they must have had an even more powerful reason to leave.
You know what that guy sounds like?
The sheriff?
He sounds like the new mayor from Family Guy.
The one that replaced Adam West.
Can I beat up a bird?
Here we go.
Alright, there you go.
Let's see.
We gotta go this way.
Weeeeee.
Wait, why can't I drive over here?
What gear?
I'm gonna put on autopilot.
Guys, this is autopilot.
Guys, that was autopilot.
Guys.
Okay, autopilot just makes you drive straight.
I've learned what autopilot is.
Let's head for that stone arch.
Taubo's just beyond it.
Yeah, it's about time.
Alright.
Oh my god, autopilot is literally just drive straight.
Wait, I can't run over... I can run over a dog.
Not dog.
A dinosaur, but I can't run over... Oh, I can.
Never mind.
I just need more... I just need more speed.
Yay!
1 XP.
I was gonna say, was it really better in the old days?
Good question.
The world's taken a turn for the worse, sure.
Wait, Luke!
But humans had plenty of problems back then, too.
Luke!
Perhaps so.
But we were never half as cruel as you demons.
What the fuck did we demons do?
We might play tricks on people, but we don't kill.
We don't kill?
Oh, I killed...
Yeah, guys, I did not kill, guys.
Humanity has always loved to blame us for it.
Those bugs never existed.
Guys, look at what they said.
They said I don't kill, guys.
They said I don't kill.
Wait, is the voice volume better now?
Or is the overall sound better?
Chat?
Just wanna be sure.
Okay.
Guys, I didn't kill, guys.
Those bugs are just in the hospital with like a broken leg, guys.
Oh my god, there's green dinosaurs!
Oh my god, they have babies, too!
Oh my god, it's a mom-dad!
Oh!
Don't worry, I'm only here for the babies.
For all the other orphaned dinos.
I'm gonna create...
I need to create families that need babies to adopt all the other orphans.
I am do...
Oh, she...
This mom has triplets!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
No!
I killed the mom!
Okay, now I have to find...
Now I have to find a single... single mom to adopt these babies.
I created orphans.
I can't believe I've done the one...
Okay, we're gonna leave one survivor.
No, we can't have any survivor or they're gonna do a revenge on us.
There's no revenge plot on me.
It's time to end the bloodline, now.
So there's no revenge plots.
There.
There were no orphans.
What do you mean?
No witnesses, guys.
No witnesses!
What did you say is true?
Perhaps, we have misunderstood you.
Now, hold on!
Don't get the wrong idea!
Alpha Raptor!
Where?
Is that him?
Oh shit!
Guys, oh my god, it's the king of all- it's the king of all- all dragons.
Am I doing any damage to the alpha raptor?
I don't know, I can't tell.
What?
It was in war, yes.
But killing is killing.
Here we go.
Alright, we're gonna kill the alpha.
Some serious stuff.
Did I just chop off his tail?
Oh my- he's okay!
He's okay, he's still moving!
Where's the alpha?
Where is he?
I'm gonna punch the alpha, Dano.
Be careful, Prince.
What's he gonna do?
Punch me?
Oh shit!
I don't- I can't- are you- go!
There's the alpha scorpion!
What did you do?
When an alpha scorpion and an alpha Dano love each other very much.
Oh my god, imagine the babies they would make.
It's love but one!
How is that alpha?
Do you think the thief will be okay?
Okay.
Oh, I don't have like a- Bro, you can- oh, you can!
Okay, I was gonna say, where the fuck is the HP?
You really cannot recommend fighting it unarmed.
I'm gonna fight him!
You can't stop me!
Watch this!
Oh!
Okay, wait, don't watch it!
Okay, okay, guys, guys!
Guys, I realize...
Guys...
Not every...
Guys, I realize...
Not every Dano I can fight, guys.
I just figured it out.
That I should not take every fight, chat.
I...
There are some points in time when it's okay to run away.
Alright, we have to go this way.
Alright.
This is where we have to go.
Woop!
Anyway, I did get to...
Uh...
Oh, on OBS remastering game, just bring it up a little small bit to round it out.
Okay, guys, close your eyes.
Close your eyes, guys.
Close your eyes real quick, guys.
Okay.
Speedrun.
Where?
There's a baby all by himself.
Hehehehehe.
Where's the bandit symbol?
I wanna go there.
I wanna go to the bandit...
Oh, shit!
There's a raptor cave!
Wait,
there's a rock here.
Can I beat up the rock?
Am I strong enough yet?
No.
I'm not strong enough yet.
Alright, guys.
There's still a point.
Why am I in this raptor cave if I can't fucking beat up the... beat up the rock?
Karma's coming.
What's that?
Karma?
I don't think I've ever heard of that word before.
Woop.
Oh my god, wait, they're red scorpions.
Inbound!
First one in ten days.
What the heck just...
All four tires punctured.
Oh, we are so unlucky.
Have at them, boys.
Go rob and blast.
And if they resist, feel free to offer.
I take it you punks are responsible?
What the...
Guys, I think we're in the wrong part of town, guys.
I don't think they're just bandits, guys.
Are we kink-shaming them, Prince?
They look fabulous.
Okay, we're gonna get these guys out.
Yay, we did it.
It's okay, they like that.
Guys, they like that.
You can tell by their outfits, they really like it.
Press RT to do an evasive action and dodge an enemy attack.
Use RT to move in the direction to evade it.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
I did that.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Oh my gosh, if only I was full HP and I didn't waste all of that on...
Yes.
If only I didn't waste my HP on that raptor.
Please, will you help?
Are you... Is this all he does?
Does he just cheer me on?
Okay, I definitely messed up by using all my HP for that one fucking raptor.
Okay, he does like two, three... a delay on the third.
Oh.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna Bowser you.
Oh!
You're gonna do another swing, right?
Oh no, he's not.
And he has like one delayed.
Oh my god, look at that!
I have no patterns!
You have a gun, Sheriff!
Use your gun!
What?!
He has a gun?!
I'll show you what I'm packing!
That's the gun, right?
Nobody's allowed to be more evil than a fiend.
Still kicking, old timer?
Yeah, thanks to you.
Never would have believed just how strong fiends are if I hadn't seen it for myself.
Oh, please.
Those guys?
They were nothing.
Yeah, they should have started off with a gun.
Then maybe I would have a problem.
By the way, Sheriff, it seems like you also have a gun.
Guys, this is why I should have taken the centaur.
I feel like the centaur would have actually helped me in that fight.
We've no choice but to walk it to Talbot.
It's not far.
Aww, are you serious?
Oh, for the... I can't believe this.
No!
Our car!
You can see it.
Who am I gonna run over?
How am I gonna run over people this time?
Alright.
I can't believe it.
Oh god.
Okay.
Beezlebutt's friends earn skill points upon leveling them.
Once you level up, open... Okay, guys.
This might be a little bit of an issue.
Oh, I got ally skills!
They're gonna actually help!
I open up ally skill ring with LB.
Passive skills take action to...
Oh my god!
You guys are actually gonna help!
Power of Darkness.
He has a vacuum.
Beezlebutt accumulates power of darkness when dealing damage to enemies or enemies.
Use the power to dish out special kit skills.
Use RB to view the skill ring menu.
Then press key for a special attack you wish to unleash.
RB to unleash a special combo in front of you.
Oh, okay.
I learned...
Okay.
I learned a special attack.
Rush.
How's this?
Oh, shit!
Okay, that looks cool.
Alright, there's... I have Rush and then...
Oh, I can like zoom out of the map.
Like this.
Okay.
Uh... Alright.
Oh, yes!
We fixed it!
I don't know how!
But we fixed it.
Okay, we're gonna learn... this.
We have new finishing move.
Press B during the combo to keep attacking.
Alright, what about...
What about our allies?
Spoilers award chances of obtaining additional items from defeating enemies.
Use this to insert their closing in and knock them out.
Okay.
I feel like we need more items.
I did it!
I fixed it, guys!
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Okay.
What's it like in Talbo?
It's a former mining town.
Not as well off as it once was.
But still the biggest town around these parts.
Hmm...
That's where they have the Aquanium mine, isn't it?
Or what's left of it.
Oh, hey, there is!
There's ores here!
Can I beat up the rocks?
I can beat up the rocks!
Aquanium veins tapped out.
Mines be shoved.
Oh my god!
Of course you used it all up.
I can beat up the rocks!
Humans never know when to stop, do you?
I say as I'm mining the resources.
Yeah, humans!
Those goddamn humans don't know when to stop!
Over mining!
Oh, hey old man!
Is that the town?
Yes, that's Talbo.
Now, you two should wait here.
It'll cause havoc if people see demons wandering around town.
I'll go on my own.
Wait, we need water and food, right?
Yeah!
Thiefs can just steal them for free.
Yeah, we don't have to spend money.
Huh?
That is why you're here, thief!
No, that's all right.
As a sheriff, I can't condone.
But you're okay with murder?
Oh, sorry, not murder.
Sorry, demons don't murder, guys.
It's just injuring them.
You have the costume, right?
The costume?
Yes, of course.
Of course, prince.
I never leave home without it.
What's the costume?
What the fuck?
Is that Santa?
Oh, this is murder on my hairstyle.
What's that supposed to...
Even if I get caught, I can just talk my way out as long as I'm wearing this.
See ya!
Oh, no, this is not...
I don't know, the bright red doesn't seem like very thief, you know, thief camouflage-y.
The ultimate costume.
Huh?
Is that a...
Oh, I got blonde Bulma!
It is.
A motorcycle.
Looks like it's in good condition.
We can always trust Santa.
I'll use this to make my escape.
Alright then.
Now to get what I came here for in the first place.
Steal the bike.
Do it!
Steal the wheels!
These will do nicely for provisions.
We could've stole the wheels!
There's plenty more for the taking.
Car jacket!
Okay, I'll grab what I need and head back.
Get food and water in town.
Alright.
If you're a spy by then you'll instantly fail the mission.
Keep your head down.
Pick up the food and water provision by holding Y.
While sneaking with RT, symbols will appear.
Okay, I need to...
Alright.
We'll grab this.
Yay!
We're gonna be fed now!
Well, I should just about do it for this month's tax.
What about the water?
But we're thirsty!
Everything I work for gets taken by the Royal Army.
I like how that's like... is it the Red Army?
Oh, sounds like these supplies are earmarked for the Royal Army.
Okay, he needs to pay taxes.
Yeah, demon taxes.
Now he doesn't trouble me one bit.
Take everything you can get, I say.
Ship.
I just like walk this way and then walk around.
Still haven't found enough food and water.
Better keep looking.
You mean X.
Still haven't found enough food and water.
Better keep looking.
Don't worry.
I make my own...
I make my own pathways.
At this rate, I'll be done in no time.
Yeah, it's like the Red Ribbon Army.
But like instead it's the Royal Army instead.
Moo?
What?
What's this cow doing?
Cow me?
Bororo cattle.
They scared my boots off.
Looks like good eating.
Alright, you're off the meat hook.
I've got places to be.
What the fuck?
He was watching me.
He was a voyeur.
I like how I don't even need to sneak.
I can just like walk around.
Oh shit, wait.
It's alright, she's not gonna turn around.
Don't worry guys.
She was never gonna turn around anyway.
I'm late.
At times like this, you Bororo are such a comfort.
Slifter than a lullaby.
Oh my god, blonde Bulma.
Spino?
You have to go south.
It's hard to spot.
Surrounded by mountains.
I'm Spider Santa.
What do you want with that desolate old place?
Don't wanna hear her voice.
Nice.
BOMA 18.
You can tell cause she's the only woman in this area with like colored hair.
Instead of black hair.
Alright, where's the other one?
Oh, it's over here.
It's not like they can hear me.
Hahahaha!
I don't need to sneak.
I can just run.
Run!
Oh my god, we can steal the tanks!
Wow!
You don't know that!
Yeah!
Beat him up!
I can't believe he would assume that!
I can't believe he just assumed that she can't fix it!
That's so fucked up!
Oh, there's a dog!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Never punished.
Let's go!
Don't need to sneak around.
I can just run.
Where is Spino?
Voice actress, can you make it sound like your old... the typical, generic old voice?
I hear it's been deserted ever since the royals stormed it decades ago.
Huh, what brings her there?
Don't know.
Strikes me as odd, though.
You think she could be up to no good or something?
Hmm... Don't know what harm she could do there if she tried.
Nothing of interest to us here.
Yeah, we don't need to go to Spino.
Unless there's more gear there.
Yeah!
I got food and water!
Perfect!
Plenty of food and water here.
Generic old lady voice 01.
Should be more than enough for us.
That booze about the tank is the most valuable piece of this haul, though.
Yay!
Better get going.
Prince is waiting for me.
Hey, she does look like the Red Ribbon Army.
Even the uniforms.
Got our requisitions?
Yeah, but they seem kinda light.
Hey!
Haven't seen you around here before.
Yeah, it was her.
She stole all the food and water.
Wait, why are you here?
She's got something to hide.
Arrest her!
Stop!
Yeah, you can tell I'm part of you guys.
I also have red.
What the fuck?
It just has two wheels.
Wait, what?
What is that car?
Well, looks like I'll be walking around.
What kind of car is that?
Wait!
It just had two wheels!
Did you see that?
It just works!
A car motorcycle!
You're back already?
You work fast.
Not just fast, but talented.
I got us some invaluable information.
Apparently, the army's got tanks sitting at its base.
Whoa, tanks?
Awesome!
We gotta steal it!
This whole game is about a tank!
We still haven't got the tank part!
Hold on there.
That's a whole lot easier said than done.
Hey, we need some car or other.
I'm not going all the way to the legendary spring on foot.
Hmm...
Well, we might as well check out this base.
Maybe we'll think of something.
So, the tank is still a rumor?
Has it yet to be real?
Look, I saw the game cover and I was on a tank.
So, that has to be real.
Your water supply points scatter around every area.
Hold Y at a water supply point to refill your HP and water gauge.
By refilling at a water supply point, you won't be able to use it again for a period of time.
Okay.
So, like this?
Where is this map's base anyway?
It's eastward of here.
Yay!
I'm healthy again.
Can I beat up a cow?
We'd best scout the area first.
No!
They know what I want to do!
Let me touch the cows!
Not fair!
What if I want to touch the cow?
I want to pet him!
I won't do anything else!
I wasn't going to punch him!
I swear!
I was not going to punch a cow!
Okay, let's go to the main objective.
No cow hugs!
Alright, so you guys want to know what it sounds like?
Yeah, I'm curious too.
Can I change it?
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Oh well, guys.
I guess...
Wait, let's see.
Message size.
Let's have it big, actually.
I feel like we should have the message size big.
I was wondering if I could change the...
Change it here for...
Oh god, sorry guys.
Change the Japanese here.
Yeah.
We don't care about those people.
What?
It's like taxes!
Sorry, I can't beat up those...
I can't beat up those raptors.
Guys, we have to do this together, guys!
Guys!
Come on, guys!
Let's do this together!
Guys, did you not remember when I said we got to bust this together as a team?
What?
I like the tin hats.
I feel like the holes just make this like...
Make it not useful.
It's not as practical with the holes in the helmet.
Oops, sorry.
Alright.
I wanna...
Wait, where's the...
Where's the...
Did it TP me?
Wait, it TP'd me.
I was trying to mine.
Where's the...
Oh, it did!
I was like, where the fuck...
Where the fuck were the rocks that I was trying to jump on?
Right here, yeah.
I can parkour this.
Watch this, guys.
Wee!
Okay, and then I guess this is where I stop parkouring.
Nevermind.
This is where the parkour stops.
But what... Can I just beat them up, guys?
I'm gonna go beat them up.
I don't need another checkpoint.
Guys, watch this.
Let me beat them up, Sheriff!
Please!
I can't punch anybody I want anymore!
This is not fair!
They won't let me punch people!
Here we go!
At least I can punch this.
If you hate the army so much, why not fight them?
Yeah!
30 years ago, the whole rebel army dared to stand against them.
But the loyal army tore them to shreds and scattered its members to the...
I'm gonna punch a bug because I'm angry.
How?
They're really that strong, huh?
I can't wait to charge into their base!
Your guns don't even hurt me!
Not even a fiend can take them head on!
You don't know that!
I'm different!
I like how they went from demon to fiend.
Like, what's the difference?
Violence is wrong, Doki.
Oh, but you didn't stop me when I took the car...
and ran it over bugs.
There's a tank!
I can't run over bugs with a tank!
That's better than a car!
Oh, I like it!
Steal it for a thief?
Do you realize what you're asking for?
Alright, I'll do something about it.
Uh, you?
You're really sure it's okay for you to steal stuff?
If it belongs to that lousy royal army, it's fair game in my book.
I'm not sure I can do anything about it.
We should be able to sneak in through the side entrance.
Honestly, yeah.
I feel like there should be more guards posted up.
Hairspray?
Yeah.
What are you going to do with that?
What are you going to do with Hairspray?
I have an idea.
Let's get closer.
Don't get spotted.
What's he going to do?
Alright.
Loot time!
Look!
Yay!
Am I going the right way?
I think I am.
Oh!
Mining time!
Yeah!
Oars!
I can't wait to customize my tank.
It's going to look so fucking cool.
Oh, there's no fall damage!
That's my favorite part.
I see.
Lucky for us.
How's the sheriff going to...
How's the sheriff going to use his Hairspray?
Okay.
Then what?
What happens, Prince?
You sneak in from the side.
What?
Why me?
Go be a decoy yourself if that's what you want.
I'm game.
Let's go!
As long as I can punch.
You're far too willing to let this human take the reigns at every turn.
I'll zip it.
Unless you got a better idea...
Then it's decided.
Yeah, old man!
I'm the boy prince!
What the fuck is he doing?
It's like a smoke bomb.
Oh, they're gonna think it's a smoke bomb.
Okay, that's good.
Run!
Okay, I was gonna say, why are they still in it?
That is actually so smart.
Who actually just said- Look, guys!
The world's a mess right now.
I don't think there's like school anymore in this world.
I'd be surprised if they can read or write.
Exploring military bases, be careful not to get spotted by soldiers.
Running or making noise will alert them, so make sure to move slowly and quietly when near soldiers.
Okay.
Is this considered running?
Better keep a low profile till we've joined up again.
Okay, that's not considered running.
Okay, that's good to know.
I wasn't sure.
Sneak up from behind and use Y to perform a stealth attack.
This will take your enemy out without alerting others.
Self-attacks to get rid of enemies blocking your way.
Hold LT which allows you to move slowly and silently.
Sorry, that was RT.
Oh, what?
Guys, he's okay.
Guys, he's gonna be okay, guys.
I didn't scare him to death because murder's wrong for the demons, apparently.
Let's see.
I feel like if you're a soldier and you can die from just pure fear, then I don't think you should be a soldier.
Parkour!
We don't murder here, guys.
That's a lie.
We don't cross, apparently.
Or cannibalism.
Murder and cannibalism is like the line for the demons.
We want people to die by natural causes.
Like fear.
Fear is natural.
They got the yellow... Oh my god, there's the yellow paint!
That's why I knew where to go, guys.
Even the ladders are yellow.
Oh, guys.
This is why I knew where to go.
I didn't even notice it.
I was just... It was subconscious.
The yellow paint was so subconscious.
I was like, I see yellow, I go.
Even the markers are yellow!
Oh my god!
What?!
Oh, now they spot me after everything I did!
Oops, they saw me.
Gotta be more careful.
No, I don't.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Alright, I'm gonna scare this guy to death too.
Boo!
Fucking... These are the worst soldiers here, not gonna lie.
These have to be... What the fuck?!
I saw a loon!
I want... I got greedy!
I got greedy!
Oops, they saw me.
Gotta be more careful.
I got so greedy!
Anyway, I'm coming back in.
Not gonna stop me.
There's like a guy right here.
Oh...
No!
Wait, is it... Did I loot this already?
Did I loot it?
Guys, it's a speedrun, guys.
Guys... What the fuck?!
Guys, it was a speedrun.
Because I already looted... It got looted.
So I don't have to do it again, guys.
I did that on purpose, because I already looted that area.
So now I don't have to loot it again, guys.
Speedrun.
You didn't see me, right?
No, you didn't.
Alright, nice.
Oh, nice!
There's an opening!
I did it.
I'm so good at stealth chat.
Alright.
I didn't get caught!
Where's your proof?
If I get caught, you would have... I would have had a game over, but I did it!
Where am I?
Oh my god, this is a fucking maze.
I'm so confused.
Hey, did you hear?
There was a big uproar at the gate.
Even the opening is yellow!
Yeah, I heard.
Man, today was just packed, wasn't it?
What's that?
What was that plotline?
Oh my god, look guys!
Where do I go next?
I wonder.
Wait, but there's loot.
Guys, sorry, but there's loot.
This is more important.
No, get off the ladder.
There's loot over there.
Oh, they are sneaky.
They are sneaky with this loot.
Because it wasn't yellow.
It wasn't yellow.
They thought I didn't see it.
They tried to distract me with the yellow.
Yo, the moon is yellow.
We should go to the moon.
Alright.
Okay, let's go.
I like how slow the crawl is though.
I think that's what I don't like about it.
It's way too slow.
Hey, did you hear?
They captured some suspicious lady.
Oh, it's blondeboma18!
Yeah, heard she had tons of maps, tools, water, but works.
Doesn't seem to be from around here.
No, I missed the loot!
Guys, guys.
Oh, it's right there!
God, why did it make the loot box yellow?
It's like they don't want me to get it.
That's so fucked up.
Okay, I can't run.
Alright.
Yay, does this mean this door is open?
No, it's not.
Okay, I got B grade steel.
Alright.
I love the yellow codes.
Hahaha!
On!
Okay, guys, I'm not going back.
It's their fault for not making the loot box yellow.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
They can't just put all this yellow in my face and then not make the loot box yellow as well.
That's just...
That's just them trying to make me not open the loot box.
That's on them.
That's not my fault.
Oh my gosh, I can.
This is just poor design.
AHHHHHHHH!
Don't climb onto the tank.
Hahaha!
Anyway, as I was saying, that was just poor level design.
Why did they make that yellow?
Hahaha!
I can't believe they made it blue.
Oh my god.
It's like they don't want me to succeed.
Hahaha!
That should be like a brighter yellow so I know it's dangerous.
We're literally at their base.
What do you mean they're everywhere?
Where do I go though?
Where's the yellow?
Oh.
No.
Boo.
Okay.
We gotta steal this.
I don't think they see me from here.
There's no way.
I'm so far from the distance.
Oh, he went the other way too so that's okay.
Alright, let's see.
We good?
Alright.
Here we go!
Uh...
Go this way.
Yeah!
Found it.
Take!
What's wrong with her?
That little hellcat really laid into me.
Guess she's dead set on staying quiet.
No, it's his self esteem.
Come on, let's get you in the med tank.
To the med tank?
Oh!
Because she punched him or something.
I thought he was like...
What about the girl?
I thought she like hurt him so badly emotionally and mentally that he had to go get like psychiatric help.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it has eyes!
That's so cute!
Oh my god, it has eyes.
It's perfect!
It's Engi!
What the fuck?
How did they get here?
Where did you guys come from?
Woman!
Oh, you're a mechanic?
We appreciate the offer.
But who exactly are you?
Can't these little details wait?
Those grunts will be back any second.
Hmm... We don't have the luxury of choice here.
Prince, let's help her out.
At this point, we need that tank just to escape this base.
We just follow the yellow back!
We don't need the tank to escape!
I mean, how the fuck did you guys get in here?
Oh my god!
Enjoy my fancam of this lady!
Hahaha!
Oh!
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
Cinematography?
Legs!
For what?
They don't have a new one, though.
Gonna have to jury-rig some old ones together.
We're gonna MacGyver this shit!
What do you mean, MacGyver?
Thanks, but this is nothing.
The protagonist is short.
Guys, it was just the... the Prince's POV, guys.
Okay?
He had to look up.
I thought you introduced yourselves.
I'm Rao.
This here's Beelzebub.
And Thief.
He did ecchi work before Dragon Ball?
This is the first time I've ever seen a demon face to face.
What?
It's like that one... that one manga artist that used to do, like, furry art.
And... furry porn... before he became famous.
Um, is it normal for you guys to run around with humans like this?
Absolutely not.
Normally, I wouldn't be caught dead with the...
Sorry, Gramps.
Could you scooch for a sec?
I have a name, thank you!
You guys didn't know?
I don't remember which one.
There was, like, a famous manga artist that...
Maybe he was in the tank.
I don't know.
He's supposed to get out of the base with it.
If you look it up, you'll find it.
They're already on alert for hostiles after that.
Yeah, the... Oh, it's the Astro!
Yeah, yeah!
The manga artist that created Astro Boy.
Yeah!
You can look up his old works.
He was really into furry art.
You two are in the tank.
There we go.
That should get us moving.
Nice job.
Your ability speaks for itself.
So, do I hide in the tank too?
And where does she sit?
You're not gonna just leave me here, are you?
It's true!
He drew, like, naked furries.
Those soldiers are coming.
We've gotta go!
No!
No choice.
Climb in.
He's like, no crime!
I forgot on purpose.
Forget it!
We've gotta hustle!
No!
There's something very important in my things.
What the fuck is that?
Why, you... planning to steal the tank all for yourself from the start, were you...
Bro, the helmets are so fucking stupid.
Why can't they just wear those, like, the red berets?
Like...
That's right.
You got shot for trying to run away.
Why'd you shoot me?
A bullet wouldn't have even scratched me!
Yeah!
I'm a demon!
No choice now.
We'll have to break through.
Time to go loud!
Every time I see their fucking helmet, I'm just like, that's so stupid.
Can I shoot it?
Guys, don't worry!
It's not murder!
Guys, see?
He's okay!
I told you!
See?
He survived!
I shouldn't waste that.
Okay, I'm gonna use bullets now.
See?
Look!
I didn't... Look, they're okay!
They just fell down because they tripped.
Guys...
Wait.
What do I have to do?
I have to go.
Do I slam it?
Guys, it's the XP, guys.
It's the XP.
Can I run him over?
Oh my god!
I can!
Oh, I should...
Boom!
Okay.
Sorry, I was too busy running people over.
Can I run over these cars, too?
Oh my god!
I can run over the cars, too!
Okay.
Let's go back.
Alright, don't worry.
Watch.
See?
Look!
Oh my god!
It's like a fucking motor car.
Like, it's a motorcycle.
It's a motor car.
Wait, that's a real car.
A unicar?
No, that's a...
A dual car.
It's like a... Oh!
Wait, a dual cycle.
It's not lethal, guys.
Motorcycle.
They're so brave.
Do not engage in infantry.
I can't help it!
I see people I shoot.
I can't!
No survivors!
Oh shit.
Guys, look at that.
I can drive without having to look in the front.
Oh guys.
Oh no.
Boom.
See the car?
Did it explode?
Guys, don't worry.
They survived.
Don't worry.
A car cycle!
They're so alive.
Because murder is my line.
Daisy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tezuka-san did very, you know, before, during, and after.
Man knew what he liked and he did it well.
I'm pretty sure, um, if like, if they put those artwork up for auction, the amount of money they can get from that is like actually crazy.
Because like, people who buy those are, they're fucking, there are a lot of suspiciously very wealthy furries out there.
And I would not be surprised if like, if they go up an auction that that, those type of artwork from Tezuka-san, they're gonna be like, oh, I'm gonna buy this.
Tezuka-san would be sold for like, like 500 grand.
It would be millions, yeah.
I'm convinced he was the first modern furry artist.
Without a single fatality!
Let's go!
What is that?
Prince, you should try heading over there.
Oh, I can like attach a tank gun!
Is this the tank part?
Looks like a main cannon.
If we install it in the tank, it'll make it way stronger.
Oh my god, I'm gonna absorb all the other tank parts.
If I remember right, the old road ahead leads to a campsite.
We can install it there.
Which way?
No, not...
A simulation.
I'm gonna simulate all the other tanks.
We should be safe from the royal...
Majin Buu tank!
Let's install the cannon you scored.
Great idea!
Let's do it!
Okay, customize vehicles.
I can customize them now!
I'm gonna use the...
What's this?
Oh wait, that's stronger.
See that?
This is me!
If I see stats numbers up, numbers go up, means stronger.
And tutorial.
That's it?
That was the tutorial?
I did it.
What?
Hey, Born Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
The guy manning the flaming wreck that was a tank are just... Yeah, they're just unconscious, guys.
Number go up equals good.
Power is welcome indeed.
Thing is though, the transmission's at its limit after that battle.
Suspension's... I learned a lot from that tutorial, guys.
We'll be walking soon if nothing's done about it.
Wait, did she get shot?
Is she okay?
Yeah.
Tried my hand at any number of things during the war.
I bet you it's gonna reveal that he used to be in the army and he's like a deserter.
Okay.
Tanks I liked.
Endless fighting I didn't.
Well, I'm glad to have another gearhead around.
Hold up.
You mean our tank's already fallen apart?
We just got it!
I can patch it up, but that's a temporary fix.
Well can't you do something, ace mechanic?
If we had the parts, yeah.
And the tools.
Of course.
You know, I've got a little business in Spino.
I knew it.
I knew it!
There's a garage there where I should be able to get this fixed up for you.
She gave me a sneak peek and then later on she charges me.
I fucking knew it.
I'm just a cash cow to her.
Spino?
She's gonna charge me for all these tank parts.
It's in the mountains to the south.
That's how they hook you in.
I think.
But don't quote me on that.
That's how they get you.
You're all the same.
Yeah, how do you know?
Didn't you say you have a business in Spino?
My free trial of tank has expired.
It's a subscription based.
I don't know what's become of it.
Only heard rumors.
Well, what have we got to lose?
Without the tank, we'll never make it to the legendary spring.
We should just go back.
No, we should just rob Spino.
Really didn't sound like a good time.
If that's settled, we'll get started on some makeshift repairs.
You guys should get some rest.
Thanks.
We'll take you up on that.
Yay!
Mission complete!
We got our tank, boys!
I wanna punch it.
Alright.
Wait, we don't have beds?
Do we just sleep on the rock?
Oh, yes.
Let me loot our... Let me loot my own loot.
Press ring to choose an item.
Replay press A to use multiple at once.
Select item to use.
Hold X to reset.
Okay.
Wait, what do I have to press again?
Um...
Guys, I forgot... How do I select my ring again?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I did it.
Repair kit restores a little bit.
Select item... How do I...
I guess you can't customize this yet.
Guys, no.
I understood.
I understood, guys.
I figured it out.
Tutorial needs a tutorial.
Alright.
Injust a battle tank control type from the options.
Other control types and settings can be adjusted to create an experience that suits your playstyle.
Alright.
I wanna see if I can upgrade.
Oh, I can!
Okay.
So, flying...
Allows you to quickly regain your stance.
Allows you to evade.
Okay, I think I'd rather have the evasion mid jump.
Uh... What about my allies?
Can I upgrade them yet?
Uh... Increase the amount of money earned from defeating enemy.
The enemy is gifted a bomb.
Okay.
We're gonna see... We're gonna get...
Rai or something.
Rai... Rau... Rau...
Deploy hairspray.
How much hairspray do you have?
Look at your hair!
I wanna assume the thief has hairspray.
Oops.
Okay, where do we go?
Is that it?
Okay.
Oh, there's a dead end.
What luck.
Don't shave his hair.
Oh my god, they have tanks!
Assimilate.
Be one with the tank.
Right?
Just destroy the real and it'll come down.
My kind of plan.
Let's get to it.
Alright, here we go.
We go in.
I'm gonna assimilate this tank.
Make us whole.
It's mine now.
Give me your tank.
No!
Let me assimilate you!
Oh my god, I can like scope in.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Don't worry, they're okay, guys.
They're fine, guys.
See, look.
They're okay.
Okay.
You would have to lower the bridge.
How do I lower it?
Oh, here it is.
Is that the real?
It is!
Is there loot around me?
Wait, there's tents here.
There's holes.
There must be loot.
If you see a hole, there's a loot in there.
I knew it.
It's okay.
Keep up.
The army don't need this loot.
They're evil.
Evil people don't need loot, guys.
Okay.
It's not like these military men might be innocent and just trying to find a place, you know.
It's not because they joined the army because it was a nice place to live and be fed and have water rather than die in their village.
No, no, no.
They're all evil, guys.
Every single one of them.
Oh, here's one here.
Oh, so much loot.
So much loot.
It might turn out to be useful later.
Anything else here?
Loot hole.
Somebody said I missed a chest here.
No, I didn't.
Oh, it's right here.
Nice.
Wait, where's my tank?
Oh, there it is.
Right in front of me.
They're all evil!
They come to me!
I just starved instead of joining the army.
Yeah.
But they don't count.
They're not real.
Oh, shit.
I should have saved my fucking thing for...
Okay, I should have saved...
I should have saved the armor piercing for the actual tanks themselves.
It's okay.
I'll be fine.
The tank will be fine.
At least that was sort of fun.
Every hole is a gloot.
Exactly, Alan.
Assimilate.
I'm not that mobile.
They're not the main character.
So they're evil.
I guess.
Steal all their resources.
They don't matter!
Yay!
Keep it.
It might turn out to be useful later.
Yeah.
I, as a demon, is going to cleanse all the evil in this world.
So only I can be the...
So I can have the monopoly.
If anybody's going to be evil around here...
It's going to be me.
The one true evil.
Who?
D'oh!
I need you to help save Sats.
Am I strong enough to defeat you?
All you need to be quite ready if there's something you're going to attack you.
Is there a Pc stock?
I'll keep you too.
Take care, Oddn.
Here we go!
Your vehicle will move forward and so this mode will be disabled.
Okay.
Actually destroy it?
You liars.
You liar.
I can't believe it.
This door is...
What kind of material is this door made out of?
Holy fuck.
Alright.
There can only be one.
Oh my god!
I shoot the bird!
What would you do if you ran into a tough enemy?
Shoot the bird!
Oh my god!
I just shoot the bird!
Don't worry.
Look, he's okay.
Look, see?
He's okay.
Woah!
There's a scorpion!
What would you do if you ran into a tough enemy?
Friendly fight.
It just works.
What gives?
I can shoot the bird!
10 out of 10.
Could you be any ruder?
Wait, am I driving backwards?
I just said it like it is.
It's okay.
This is how you drive now.
Do I really smell weird?
When was the last time you showered?
I honestly can't say.
Oh my god!
Look at them!
It's so cute!
Guys!
Guys, look how cute this is!
They're having a moment!
I'm not a bad person.
Right?
Oh my god, loot!
They're like, my giant!
Don't worry.
You can leave.
Don't worry, you'll see your child in heaven.
Oh my god, there's mines!
There's ores here!
Where are mine?
Loot, loot, loot, loot.
Loot.
And then...
I punched the ores.
I'm just helping them reunite!
Exactly!
You want that mom to live her rest of her life in grief and depression?
I'm doing a good thing even though I might have caused her depression?
I was putting her out of her misery!
Oh my god, I hit it.
I hit those.
Nice.
Look, loot is important, chat.
It might be useful later!
Okay, I'm gonna use up all the ammo so I can reload.
I think that's the worst part.
The reload.
Like manually...
You have to use all the ammo to reload.
I can't believe it's only 2 XP.
I think they try to prevent you from killing the wildlife.
Because they don't give you any XP.
Chat, don't justify your sins!
Oh, I can?
How do I reload?
What's that?
King army?
Who's that?
Why planes?
Wait, what?
Why did they outlaw planes?
Where did he grab the helmet?
Oh, I can't see the helmet.
Tank 104, report.
Oh my god, look at his hair.
That's the guy that definitely used hairspray.
Do you read me?
Is your transmitter broken 104?
I like how it's like, Is your transmitter broken?
And then like, how would I...
Okay, like...
If it's broken, I won't be able to hear that.
What the f...
You had it.
Must be radio trouble.
Fine.
Let's move on.
I love that little like, eyelash detail that like he always does for his characters.
When they're like, when they're like, evil, but they're like, flamboyant evil, the little eyeliner and then the eyelash at the bottom.
I love that character trait that he does.
We need to hide!
Take cover!
Under that boulder!
Alright!
It just works, guys.
Is this really going to work?
Let's just see how things play out.
Napspace reports someone has stolen a tank.
Number 104.
The perpetrator has not been spotted.
But is capable of handling a tank.
I repeat, Napspace!
Turn us around quickly!
Why is that crooked to hamburger?
Thinks he can fool General Ari, does he?
We gotta change the numbers on our tank!
Guys!
How did they know?
Too loud!
Biel, uncover the tank!
We have to find!
I told you to call in Prince Bielsebub!
I'll take him out myself!
It's okay, I'm going to shoot the plane.
I have so much ammo!
What does it do?
Shoot back?
Watch this.
Over there!
Head for the high ground!
Wait, the high ground?
No!
What do you mean?
I can't fucking pull up!
Oh my god, he's right.
He's right.
They won't be able to hurt us without their machine gun.
Take that down first.
Which one?
There?
I got it.
We're going to counter attack.
Hide behind those rocks.
You can boost to avoid attacks.
Just make sure to watch out for overheating.
Okay, I got you.
I got you, sir!
Try slipping behind a rock to get the leeway to reload safely.
Don't worry, sir.
I got you!
I'm hiding!
Oh!
It looks like we've managed to give them the...
How do you reload?
There's no reload button!
There's literally no reload!
We tell them from behind, I felt like I was lying to you about reload!
...from high ground.
If hitting the machine gun's too chancy, keep aiming for the tank.
Okay.
I know you can do this!
B is not reload!
It's the swap car- It's okay, I'm in their blind spot.
Look at the top!
Oh my god!
There's a top right?!
Oh my-
Guys, guys, did you guys know top right, there's instructions over there?
Did you guys know that?
Did you see?
Did you see it?
I'm learning guys!
I'm learning!
Oh god, oh god, look.
I can just hide behind here.
The blind spot.
He's so confused guys.
Look!
Look at that fool!
He's so confused.
Oh no, oh no, oh no!
Oh no!
He doesn't know where I am!
God, we gotta head to high ground.
We have to head to high ground!
Okay!
You know what?
I don't even need a- I don't need to destroy the machine gun.
I can literally just shoot it.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Dokia's best when she's illiterate.
She's perfect.
Illiterate and dumb.
And dumb.
We're trying to bomb us!
Anticipate the enemy's course and cut them off!
Bombs away!
It's only a matter of time before nothing's left of us but a smoking crater!
See!
That's a water tank?
Nooooo!
The free water!
Lift the front end!
And try to shoot straight up!
It's no good!
Even at max output!
We still win!
We weigh 1562 kilos!
How do you know that?
What does that say?
Never ask a tank how much it weighs, guys.
That's still as much as a normal car!
What do you think you're doing?
Get back in the tank now!
What, you think my help's gonna make it heavier?
Oh shit!
That's right!
Run!
Keep pushing!
We got this!
What if I just stop?
Would I crush my allies?
What if I don't do it?
Oh, nothing happens.
Okay, there's no consequences for my actions.
I just thought it'd be funny if there was a game over screen where the tank just crushes them.
I can't believe it!
Never punished.
Quick!
Assimilate!
Become one with the tank.
With the mother tank.
Thief, we managed to pull through that somehow.
We did!
Odd though.
That plane seemed to be transporting a massive amount of water.
If that's true, the king's water supply must be in the direction it came from.
Meaning that it must also lie to the south of here.
Yeah, like where did they grab all that water?
They know where the spring is!
You telling me this legendary spring we've been looking for all this time...
is really the king's water supply?
If that's true, doesn't that mean this whole journey's been for nothing?
That's not nothing.
We're just gonna raid the camp.
Wait!
The general's in there!
At this point, we've got to see it through.
Interrogate him!
He's not dead!
Because nobody dies in this game.
Guys, remember that.
Just kill the king.
Uh oh.
We better get to... that town fast!
It's called Spino.
Yeah, back!
Come on, let's go!
Something's on the ground near the tank.
Near my tank?
Where?
Alright, come on guys!
Let's go!
It's time to assimilate!
Absorb for the mother tank!
Where is the people at?
Because they're not dead, right?
They're alive, right?
What happened to the people?
Guys, did you know RB was reloaded this entire time?
That's right.
For the good of the country, we want to put an end to the water shortage.
Oh, I can destroy the rocks now!
I realize!
We are!
Once we find that spring, I'm gonna take a leak in it.
Oh my god.
Oh, he is...
Don't ruin the drinking water!
Oh no, he is evil.
Look, it wouldn't matter!
There's animals already in the drinking water.
So like, technically the animals already peed in the springs.
So adding my pee...
Oh no!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
All I'm saying is...
It wouldn't make...
That much of a difference!
It is!
Okay, let's see.
Alright, we gotta...
Do our allies stuff.
Okay, uh...
I want more money.
Sounds about right.
All I'm saying is that it wouldn't make that much of a difference!
Ooh, heavy machine gun.
Damage up.
Okay, but damage is higher.
So that means it's better.
Here we go!
Alright.
Look!
I'm just saying!
We're trying...
The pH levels are too low!
So I'm upping the pH levels!
Who's talking?
Wait, I can turn on the radio?
Who's Zeyu?
Oh, Supreme Commander Zeyu.
Is that old...
Wow, Rao!
That's suspicious!
How do you know about the Supreme Commander?
It seems all too clear by now.
What the fuck?
We can safely assume that those vermin are heading...
Oh my god, it is Mad Max.
...to the bottom source.
What?
They are the better of us!
Order all the main tanks to stand guard around us!
What the fuck?
Do not let them near that water!
Oh my god, this is Mad Max!
Meanwhile, we'll use the media to root them out of their little hidey hole!
And exterminate them once and for all!
It's like, what if Frieza's little, like, ball vehicle thing was just a person?
Sir, yes sir!
Those renegades won't get past me!
Honestly, I don't know.
Who steals a tank?
This ought to be a fine honor.
Like, anybody?
I'd steal a tank!
It's a fucking tank!
Looks like my glory actually has a spine for once.
Monster Envy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Toriyama loves old geezers as villains!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
So that really is where the King's water source is located!
Who wouldn't?
You wouldn't download a tank, would ya?
It sounds like there's some secret surrounding it.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Who's gonna change Crappy's typing?
Only one way to find out!
Let's head south!
Alright.
It's getting dangerous!
Ooh, I love danger.
You call this fun?
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
Wait, can I- Whoa, free loot!
Full speed ahead!
I can't believe they would just leave the loot there!
Out in the open, just for me!
I'll keep it.
It might turn out to be useful later.
What's this?
Oh, there's a- There's lore!
Oh my god, if somebody's like- If somebody's loot, they're gonna have to come back here, right?
It might turn out to be useful later.
Well, they don't need to come back here anymore.
Thanks for- Oh my god, Ben died!
Thank you!
Thanks for playing Zenland!
Assimilate exactly!
All tanks gotta assimilate into the mother tank.
Can I drive off this?
Oh my god, there's no fall damage!
There's fall damage.
Guys, I don't know if you know this, guys, but there's fall damage.
Okay, am I going the right way?
I'm lost already.
Oh no, after driving- Oh, this way.
After driving off the cliff, I don't know where I'm heading.
Alright, this is the end.
This way.
Alright, I learned that there was indeed a fall damage.
And now, I do not have the repair thing anymore.
Are there Royal Army soldiers all over Zenland?
There's even a bunch near our village.
Look just ahead.
See the bridge there?
Spino is right beyond it.
Is that Spino?
Spino, huh?
Oh, that was- Okay, I thought that was the village.
Guys, I knew there was a barrier.
Guys, I shot because I knew there was a barrier.
Spino's just on the other side of these doors.
Come on, let's go in already.
I'm dying to see the sights of a whole new town.
Oh my god, new town!
I was testing the defenses.
Exactly.
Damn, they have good defenses, guys.
No wonder the rebel army is so good.
Okay.
They're still alive.
It's Doki proof.
Why is there no one living in this town?
The defenses were so good!
I literally shot a fucking missile!
So I was told.
My visitors are rare around these parts.
Are you folks travelers?
Yes.
Oh my god, is he also old?
I'm this town's mayor.
Now, I know you just got here.
But I'm afraid that I'm going to have to ask you to leave.
What?
I'm the town's mayor.
Why?
May I at least ask why?
Yeah!
What did I do?
I didn't shoot your gate.
I swear.
We can't welcome outsiders.
Hold on a minute.
Mayor Tor.
What did I do wrong?
I swear.
Yeah, I swear.
You shot the gate, Doki.
That's a lie.
Don't believe I ever heard that.
No, it wasn't me.
There's no cameras to prove anything.
You know who I am, young lady?
I have alibi.
Yes.
I've only heard about you from Longo, though.
Longo?
Who's Longo?
I know only one person by that name.
The same one, no doubt.
He wanted me to give you this letter.
Take a look.
Let's see then.
Hmm?
Why, this is the symbol of the rebel army.
So, the old war horse is still kicking, is he?
Who the fuck is Longo?
Do you trust me now?
Why does the merchant sound like the guy from Sk- Look, like, in the world of voice acting, there's like ten people.
I suppose so.
You're free to use it, as you see fit.
Thank you.
You worked some magic back there.
The man who raised me is an old friend of the mayor's.
That's all.
What was in the letter?
Just a request to allow me to use the garage.
And tinker around to my ticking heart.
And why exactly did you need to risk life and limb to use this specific garage?
Well, I mean, just look at it.
I mean, like, yeah, like, this garage.
It literally has arms coming from the ceiling.
It's been put through its paces, but it's well maintained.
The control console's working.
The power arm moves.
And all the other stuff is working.
And a whole smorgasbord of spare parts and tools.
Smorgasbord.
You won't see a full-service pit stop nearly as good as this anywhere outside the army.
I suppose, but...
She's right!
But what?
Enough with the chit-chat.
Can you fix our tank or not?
No.
What if she says no?
Also, I pinned the message from Bandai.
I'm gonna have my egos...
Guys, you might see my ego, like, from the moon for, like, the next month, guys.
We're gonna talk to children?
Hello, kid.
Come on!
Let's go!
Child...
Do you have money?
No!
Uh...
Demon...
Chill out.
I'm not gonna eat you or anything.
You're not?
Glad you're one of the nice ones.
One of the nice ones?
What do the evil ones do?
Cause apparently, we're not allowed to kill.
So, like, what's the worst I can do at this point?
Like...
You're talking to the Fiend Prince!
Beelzebub!
Oh, I see.
Glad you're a nice prince.
Ugh...
Whatever.
How do you like Spino?
Great place, huh?
Yeah...
A great big dump.
I'll admit.
It's seen better days.
Dump?!
Ages ago, the Royal Army attacked the town.
That's how it ended up.
But my hard work's gonna put Spino on the map.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
You're a kid!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With all the assimilation happening, I expect this to become the Cell Saga.
Also, do you know about Toriyama's Q Vault?
He designed a real car.
Wait, he made a real car?!
I didn't know that.
He has plans.
You're a five years old child.
What are you gonna do?
I'm a child.
What is this child gonna do?
Okay.
Oh, hey!
Old lady!
Talk to me.
I'm important.
Hello there.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
Look, see?
She talked to me!
Oh, she doesn't even have voice acting.
Like, oh, what the fuck?!
That old lady has voice acting and she doesn't?!
Hello there.
Wait, they all say hello there!
You have the same voice as the other old lady!
Okay, at least we know it's not her.
It's not just her.
What the?!
Demons!
Wait, he's me!
Just like me!
Take what you want.
But I beg you, spare the children!
The children?
We're not crooks.
You have nothing to fear from us.
Um, hello?
We're demons?
You should absolutely fear us.
We're scared.
We're demons.
Prince, that's not helping.
Keep quiet for a moment.
Sorry for frightening you.
We merely want to ask you something.
Oh?
What?
We're headed south.
No of us safe.
We have a safe route we can take.
South?
I don't have good news for you.
What?
Why not?
The royal army has blockaded off all routes headed south of here.
No getting past them.
And there's no way around?
Mmm...
Only if you can make it across the East Valley.
There's no bridge though.
It collapsed a short while ago.
I'll make my own bridge!
If I shoot enough rocks on the side, it'll start piling up on the ground that like a bridge will show up.
If you think about it.
If you keep throwing rocks in the pit, the rocks will eventually pile up into a bridge.
the rocks will eventually pile up into a bridge.
You know these parts better than me.
That old guy over there?
It's true.
It's called engineering.
Engineers will vouch for me.
Right?
Engineers in chat!
Am I right?
And there's only one answer.
Very true.
Masterclass of terraforming.
I like how all the kids have like voice acting.
Oh, I'm cute!
You're adorable too, mister!
Take that back!
No one's scarier than me!
Bro, you're old!
Looks like we're in the same boat!
Well, people aren't scary.
You just push them.
And then there'll be a problem.
And then you gotta make sure you don't get sued.
Fix the bridge for us, would ya?
How would I do that?
Look at the state of this town.
We have neither the people nor the resources to fix the bridge.
Hmm...
In that case, our only option is to penetrate the blockade.
That's what I'm saying!
They're not scary!
Cause like, they're old.
They're weak.
You want to fight the army?
Count me out!
What other choice do we have?
Why are you so determined to travel south?
We're hoping to find a spring.
An end to the war.
And the water shortage.
There's like no muscle left in them.
But I don't see how you'd be able to cross that ravine without a bot that excels at jumping.
A jumping bot?
Where can we get one of those?
There are mentions of them in the rebel army's old files.
But I suppose you need a real jump bot.
Not records of one.
Then again, that girl with you seemed to know her way around machines.
Should we try to pick her brain on the ground?
Good idea.
If anyone will know, it's her.
Alright, so we just had to talk to- Oh my god!
We're breaking into his home!
Oh I can't punch into his home.
Wait, that's your home?
Can I steal your water?
Oh I can steal your books!
Oh it's just a diary.
Lango's diary.
Oh it's lore!
Do I have skill points?
I don't.
How do I look at lore?
Where the fuck is the lore?
Ohhhhh we're not looking at the lore!!
Guys...
It might look like we're never gonna look at lore...
That's okay...
We never wanted to read anyway I guess.
Wait, oh I forgot to talk to her.
Or a quest.
Or for items?
Okay, what are these?
Health drink, repair kit, firepower kit, B-grade steel, uh, steel, uh, sharp, shock-absorbing rubber.
I don't need any of that.
I have enough loot.
Alright.
It's okay.
We can't read anyway, guys.
We never, we don't, finally, I can pretend, I don't have to pretend that I can read.
Thank God.
Wait, who's that?
Is that a demon or a cat?
It's a cat!
She has paws.
He looks like a demon.
He has paws.
Seen this guy before, thief?
Nope.
Can't say I have.
Oh, just because he's a demon.
I know a lot of different kinds of demons, you know.
You assume that just because he's a demon, he knows all the other demons?
Wow.
Stands to reason there would be entire types, even idols.
That's fucked up.
What the fuck is that?
Where's his nose?
Where the fuck is his nose?
Hey, who are you?
Don't beat me.
The name's Lassie.
It's like, what if Majin Buu...
What if Majin Buu was really into cats?
Cat Krillin.
Wait,
then what are you?
So, a cat-like thing.
Why were you sleeping here?
Wanna know?
Then hand over something... rare.
Majin Buu.
Wait, that's good.
It's Majin Buu.
Like this ancient coin.
You can usually find them in ruins.
Is that a fucking cat?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, uh, thanks.
I'm gonna go get some food.
What's that?
You wanna trade this right back to me for something good, you say?
Oh yeah, of course.
Wait, free loot.
Well, if you insist.
Take this storage capsule and exchange.
A storage capsule.
I can hold more gear.
This beauty right here can shrink even the biggest fuck down to pocket size.
Oh, it's capsules.
If you find something good in the ruins...
It's all connected.
I'll give you something even better.
Capsule court.
See ya.
Oh my god, this is like a thousand...
Like, what the fuck?
Where did he go?
Holy shit.
His people need him.
Oh my god, it's like a thousand years after the earth died.
Not after the earth died.
After the earth became sand land.
We never so much as learned why he was sleeping there.
Code, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ma!
There's a weird fucking cat outside.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everything's connected.
It'll be incredibly useful down the road.
The Toriyama multiverse.
Technically there is.
Because Dr. Slump and Dragon Ball Z had a crossover.
So there is a multiverse.
They all...
Wouldn't dream of swiping it.
The cinematic universe.
Really?
The Toriyama cinematic universe is real.
Looks
brand new.
Now she'll be able to stand a little rock and...
TCU.
Like I said, ace mechanic.
Just bring her in if she breaks again.
What about building us something new from scratch?
Look, I may be good, but it takes way too complicated to build from square one.
I'm not a tank.
A bot.
One that can jump.
Come again?
Oh my god.
My tank's gonna be able to jump?
Okay, I get it.
Solid plan.
Appeals to the gearhead in me.
Does that mean you think you can do it?
What the fuck is a jump?
Probably.
I'm trying to figure out...
If you give me a coreframe, that is.
A coreframe?
What's that?
Yeah.
Can you speak...
Can you rephrase that in apex terms?
Remember how I said I can't build a tank from scratch?
That's because I don't have and can't build its most complex inner workings.
Jump bot?
Same deal.
I need the core parts to get started.
Well, that's a bummer.
We don't have a coreframe.
Not yet.
She's gotta find another tank system.
Simulate.
A junkers market?
She just needs an octane pad.
Thanks, man.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for explaining it in apex terms, guys.
It was really helpful.
It's so weird whenever there's like a little... like I can't move before like the quest thing goes like quest complete.
So every time that little like pause, I'm like, why can't I move?
Is my game bugged?
You can use the garage.
There you can create, upgrade and switch vehicle parts as well as choose which vehicle to use.
Wait, I can use more than one vehicle?
Spindle will grow as you complete side quests, gaining new build...
Oh my god!
It's like Animal Crossing 2!
The more I do...
Oh my god, dude, it's like...
It's like anime Fallout!
Oh my god, this game has everything!
Anime Fallout 4, anime Mad Max.
This game has everything!
Gaining new buildings and then cabinets.
As you go along, you might find new...
Oh, I can't.
I was just about to say that.
It's like, you can get new stores and new products and existing stores.
Completing side quests is most certainly to your benefit.
Anime World of Tanks and Anime World of Thunder!
It has everything.
Alright.
Let me know if you want to upgrade.
Just bring me the material and I'll have it souped up and raring to go!
Does she just live here?
Wait, she's not going to be my...
She's not going to like follow me anywhere?
No!
No more...
What the fuck...
Look!
We need like at least like one female in this team.
Guys, this is getting it.
There's too many guys here.
We need to diversify.
It's like, it's like those like, uh, like those like, uh, like shows where there's always like the one, the one female to make sure, to make sure the team has everybody.
It's just too old guys.
Too many old people.
Someone please pick female.
Oh, wait, she's back?
What the f-?
Wait!
Oh my god!
She didn't leave!
Thank god!
Now this team is balanced.
This team is balanced now.
Yay!
This is the team guys!
Oh, thank god.
We're like, we're like chipping down rescue rangers!
Oh my- Wait, where did she go?
She just wants to shop.
She's only here to shop.
The dream team.
Out of the chipping down rescue rangers!
This is basically it!
What a team.
I'm Chip.
He's Dale, cause we're both the same height.
He's the, uh, that, that- I forgot the name.
The guy with the funky- Cause he has a mustache too!
He also has a mustache!
Oh my god!
We're literally ch- And then- And then!
She's the- The female one!
She's- He's Launchpad!
Who's the fly?
The fly's the tank.
That's who- That's who's the fly.
The fly's the tank guys.
Gadget!
Yeah, gadget!
Alright.
So I can...
Uh...
Look, the only people I remember in the Chippendale rescue ranger- Like the names.
The only names I remember from the Chippendale rescue rangers was Chippendale.
Because they- Because it's Chippendale!
I really don't know any of the other names.
I just remember the female rat, the rat with the fucking mustache, and the fly.
Literally the title.
There was a fat cat?
Oh yeah!
There was a fat cat!
Cause he was fat and was a cat!
Alright.
Capsule menu, choose vehicle.
Uh, okay.
The vehicle inside a capsule can be charged.
Change the cap.
I only have one tank though.
Dangerous.
Enemies on a map such as monsters will attack you.
Enemies are- are high-level so watch out.
Okay.
Uh...
How did you forget about a lord and savior gadget that created that one cult- Oh my god!
Yeah, there was- there's a Russian cult surrounded- surrounded about the- the female rat gadget.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna steal the- I'm gonna GTA this dinosaur.
Okay.
Let's see.
Autopilot, jump, intimidate.
I can intimidate?
Monsters won't attack when you're riding a raptor so you can explore safe- how your raptor will run away.
My raptor's gonna run away?
I'm GTA-ing right now.
Okay, intimidate.
Oh, that's cool.
I don't like those little sack things on the back of its tail.
Because usually those sack things on the back of its tails...
For like, actual real life action.
Animals, Grand Theft Auto.
Yeah.
I'm GTD-ing right now.
Grand Theft Auto.
Okay.
For biology facts.
Usually when there's a huge sack behind- like for the animal, it is used for like...
Um...
It is used for attracting the females.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Um...
Cool.
Thank you, Donald.
But it's usually used for like, you know...
Mating purposes.
It is.
It's typical animal biology!
Where?
That?
This one's for sitting.
It's where the pheromones come out!
What the fuck is that?
You tell my father and we're through!
Is that another Donald?
Oh my god, guys, we're gonna...
We're...
What is that?
Is that Donald?
It's a traveler!
Oh my god!
Can my Donald...
My Donald needs a girlfriend!
Is it okay we do an arranged marriage between our Donalds?
Hello?
Oh, yeah, that...
This one has to be female.
Look, it's perfect!
You can tell...
You can tell that Donald is female!
Because my Donald's bigger!
Oh my god, what if we just rob this guy?
Our Donald now.
Our Donald now!
Okay.
Let's see, we'll go this way.
Talk to that merchant?
Alright.
Okay.
Hello.
I wanna talk to you.
Raptors and Wani prowl the road to the battleship.
I've been losing sleep worrying about them getting my cargo.
Is that it?
Dark energy.
Power of darkness?
What the fuck is power of darkness?
Can I like attack them?
Hello, friend?
Friend.
Hey.
Hey, the...
He's not looking.
You wanna come with us?
Look.
She's busy with the kids.
You wanna come with us?
Alright,
let's see.
Where do we go?
Okay, we go this way.
2000.
That's so far.
But she's so fast though.
My dino's really fast.
Hey, baby girl.
Let's see.
What does the jumping look like?
Oh my god, loot!
Oh, I can loot here too.
Hey there.
Hey, baby girl.
I show you my thermones.
Hahaha!
Please respond!
I think it-
The key, please!
What?
What did I do?
The ocean's right outside of Sand Land, isn't it?
Wait, can I farm with you?
Oh, I can farm with my dino!
It's so convenient!
I like how they're just following me from the back too.
I totally showed you my tail, bub.
Please respond.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I didn't do anything wrong.
I like how... I think my favorite part is that even though I'm on the dino, they have to run after me.
I think that's the funniest part.
They have to like... they don't get any type of transportation.
They gotta follow me.
Let's see.
I wanna go to a radio tower.
Parkour!
Dino parkour!
Let's go.
There's like something here.
Wait, is that town over there?
There's like so much... Yeah!
It's all over Sandland.
Wait.
No!
Don't shoot my guy!
Don't shoot him!
Okay, I'm gonna park you right here.
I don't wanna lose you.
Okay?
You're gonna stay here.
Stay here, okay?
Stay here!
I need the loot!
I can't lose the dino.
It's actually so convenient.
Wait, is that missile?
Oh my god, he has a fucking missile.
It's fine.
I'm stronger.
He can't aim.
They're like star troopers.
Or stormtroopers.
Yeah.
No, don't run away!
No, I parked him!
I parked the raptor, guys!
There's no way!
No!
Don't say that!
Use materials to repair.
Once repaired, tower will provide you with a map of the icon.
Can I?
Can I though?
I parked the raptor!
There's no way.
We had like a bond.
The raptor and I had a bond.
Where did he go?
No!
I parked you and everything!
What?
Guys, I got dino jacked!
There's no way.
He would never run away.
Someone jacked my dino.
Guys!
There's been a robbery!
Somebody jacked my dino!
I've been dino jacked!
This is serious!
Crime is not a joke!
According to the map, this area is near the center of Sandland.
Someone GTA'd the dino I GTA'd.
I can't believe it.
The steep cliffs make traveling north or south of here a serious challenge.
I can't believe someone downloaded my dino.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Where do I go?
I'm lost now.
Oh my god.
I've been trying to get to this cave.
Oh no!
Guys, I think I'm a little lost.
I'm so sad.
Guys, I'm so sad.
We gotta file.
We gotta call the cops.
We gotta file a police report.
This is important!
My fucking car!
Oh god.
Whoa!
I'm so sad.
How... How am I going to cope?
This is not the same.
Oh my god!
Wait!
A simulate!
It's time for a simulation!
It's a simulation time.
Alright, nice.
Guys, it's okay.
It exploded but they'll be okay.
You gotta remember there's no fatalities here.
A simulate.
Oh, he found money!
Nice.
Alright.
There has to be loot in here.
Consume the metal.
Return to the mother tank.
Alright, loot.
Loot.
Yeah!
Loot!
According to the map, this area is near the center of the cave.
This is the center?
So we can reach a bunch of places from here, huh?
Wait, where did my tank go?
Did I got fucking GTT'd?
Not really.
The steep cliffs make traveling north or south of here a serious challenge.
Pretty inconvenient for a central hub.
I almost got... I can't believe it.
I almost got Grand Theft Tank.
But it's okay.
I have more capsules.
But if there's a whole junkers market right below...
Look!
Oh my god, loot!
Surely those junkers have long since stripped it of anything valuable.
My loot now.
If that's true, a core frame for a jump bot...
...is probably gonna cost us a pretty penny.
It's okay, guys.
I've been... I've been a loot goblin.
We have so much loot.
We're so rich now.
Oh no, I have to reload.
Don't worry.
We're gonna kill some scorpions.
This has to be enough money.
Oh my god, there's more loot!
Let's go into this suspiciously dark cave.
Let's not.
Get in the tank!
Get in the tank, bees above!
Okay.
It's okay.
He's not gonna slap me while I bring out the tank, right?
Oh!
He definitely slapped me.
What?
Get in the pocket tank!
There we go.
Boom.
Now I can...
Now I can loot the suspiciously dark cave.
Yay!
Another loot page!
Man, I sure wish I could read.
Loot.
We need to keep our bearings passing between the cliffs.
It's easy to lose them.
Gotta have that loot!
Guys, I know how to read the map.
I might be illiterate.
But I can look at picture books.
Do I need...
Do I need... To drink water?
Nah, we don't need to stay hydrated.
All right.
We gotta...
Okay, let's kill these scorpions for more loot.
And then we'll run over the babies.
Okay, we'll attempt to run over the babies.
Water is for the weak.
Is there more loot over here?
Can I?
No.
Aw, it's like too far up.
Okay, we'll go this way, I assume.
Fine, we're almost there!
Jonesy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, what's up here?
Don't worry, I'm gonna help you!
My job here is done.
Get over here!
How the fuck did I get... Oh, I get up from here!
I did it!
I helped!
There's ruins here?
Throughout your travels, you'll encounter people attacked by monsters or gangs.
Save them and your...
I love getting rewarded for my efforts!
Alright, pay up.
Pay up!
My fees aren't cheap.
Jonesy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hi, Doki.
With all the sand you find, it's coarse, rough, and dirty.
I'm not irritating.
Does it get everywhere?
I fucking hate sand.
I say yes, I play Sand Land.
Wait, what's my...
Did he give me anything?
What did he give me?
What the fuck?
I don't do good things for free!
There's a price for everything.
Oh my god, two bullets and he's dead.
That has to be a baby.
Scammed.
I can't believe it.
I got scammed.
You should have given me his bag.
What's this?
Ooh!
What is this ruins?
There's so many baby scorpions here.
I beat up a bug.
Nice.
Holy shit!
Can I summon a fucking tank here?
Oh my god!
There's no Professor Oak here to stop me!
I can summon a tank indoors!
Holy shit!
I can ride my tank indoors, guys!
The ocean is right outside of Sand Land, isn't it?
Can't we get water from there?
Oh no, guys, my tank's a little thick.
I choose you, tank!
My tank was a little thick, guys.
Sand Land's surrounded by a vast desert and steep cliffs.
Dang!
Guess we really do need a water force.
Alright.
Okay, uh...
Nice.
Oh, no wonder I need a tank down here.
I was supposed to bring a tank down here to blast that.
Hello?
Whoa!
Is this lore?
Is this demon ruins?
What's this?
Where do I go?
Oh, there's a door here.
Wait...
Is there...
Are those, like, beautiful old, ancient ruins?
Let me destroy it.
Sorry, I got a little British there for a sec.
Oh, weird world, man.
Ruining all this to find water for other people.
I'm not that noble.
Only death can bring us if we don't help each other.
Oh, there's a door here!
Alright, we go this way.
I don't like that.
I don't like those bugs.
The ones with like million... the millipedes.
I have filled that museum.
That got too detailed.
What did I get?
I got an ancient gold... Oh, I got the gold coin for the cat!
For Miao Jin Bu.
I guess that's what the coins... what the ruins are for.
If I don't look at them, they don't exist.
Oh, millipedes incentive...
I hate that.
I hate it.
I hate them.
Especially like they can be like really big too.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Bring out the tank!
Deadpool,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Beatbros love millipedes.
You know I saw a short that's saying that like...
The Prince Charming in Cinderella...
Um, is a feet guy.
Because who else would go like door to door for like thousands of... hundreds of towns trying to find his like...
with just a glass slipper.
Just think about that.
It makes sense guys.
It makes sense.
He's 100% a feet guy.
Hey guys.
I'm here for the jump bot.
Hello.
Oh, you look like a bad guy.
It's romantic not a...
Sure.
You can tell yourself that.
And he somehow found the real person with the same feet size that he knew 100%.
Yeah.
After checking hundreds of people.
She was literally the only one that had the same foot size for the glass slipper.
Out of every...
How would he know?
Ha ha ha ha.
Now scram.
Oh my god!
There's another dino!
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh my god.
There's another dino for me to GTD.
Alright, let's see.
I think I can like customize my vehicle, right?
I have like chips.
Oh, I need it locked.
It's like locked.
I need to like unlock it.
I feel like I don't need any of these power-ups, not gonna lie.
Hello.
Workshop.
I have so many mats.
I don't need to buy anything.
Okay.
Free dino.
Look, somebody stole my dino.
So I have the right to steal somebody else's dino.
It's a...
Demon is talking to me.
It's just the cycle of life.
No, no.
What should I do?
It's the end for me.
I don't wanna die.
Dino for dino.
Pay it forward.
What the heck are you going on about?
No one's trying to kill you.
But my granny told me I didn't want to die.
If a demon spoke to me.
Then why are you still alive?
Yeah, why are you still alive?
Equivalent exchange, exactly.
You're right.
That is strange.
You are a demon, right?
Enough of this nonsense.
Give us the jump-off parts already.
I don't have anything like that.
You don't?
Then tell us who does.
Yeah, who has it?
So I can beat them up.
But I can't just keep talking to demons like this.
Why not?
Get to the point.
If you're scared of my words.
You don't want to see what my fists can do.
Yeah.
I punched a lot of baby dinosaurs.
And I felt nothing.
I have empathy, guys.
I swear.
He always has the latest info.
Poor, huh?
Let's go pay him a visit.
Alright.
I'll go pay him a visit.
Do you have stuff behind here that I can't see?
I mean, that I can rob?
I mean, borrow?
Wow!
Look at all these gems!
Gems?
Can I look around a bit?
Sure.
But don't get lost.
Oh my god.
He's like the dad in the team.
I told you!
It's just like Chip and Deb Rescue Rangers!
He's just like him!
What's this?
Hunter?
Is this a side quest?
Oh!
You earn rewards for taking out bad guys.
I don't see Hunt requests and reporting back once you completed them.
Okay.
I'm gonna accept that.
Diamonds, boss.
Oh, god.
It's those fetish freaks again.
It's the BDSM gear, guys.
And then Bandit.
Oh my god.
It's another tank to assimilate.
Oh my god!
Look at that!
It reminds me of the planes with the angry faces.
We're going to accept all of them.
Okay.
Oh wait, no!
No, I'm gonna accept all of them.
They're all gonna die.
I mean, pass out.
Tricky jumper.
Oh, is this a jumper?
Oh, that's what the jumper is gonna look like?
No, what if I wanna kill... I can't take anymore?
I wanna be a bounty hunter!
Bro, screw fucking finding water for people.
Woman.
What is that supposed to mean?
Hey, I'm the one you're supposed to be surprised by.
Apparently, junkers consider her to be a rarer.
So, uh, what are you looking for?
Could it be a date?
Oh, a female?
Do you know where we can find a core frame for a junk bot?
Oh, so...
You're here on business.
I mean, sure, I know where to find them, but...
It'll cost you.
After all...
You gotta take a shot.
It's even rarer than demons, apparently.
Negotiate.
Don't worry.
You're not free.
What do you want?
I have a woman here to negotiate for me.
Uh, what do you think?
Money?
Duh.
Sorry, but our funds are limited.
Can't you just tell us...
Yes, tell us what you want.
Maybe that generous young lady there could foot the bill.
I'm just as broke as the rest of you.
Just give him a... a small date.
There's another way to use the baby!
Whoa!
Hey, I'm a sheriff...
I said that as a joke, bro!
Bro!
What the fuck?
What?
That's all he wants?
What the fuck?
Please, dragoons.
Sheep.
You're all sheep.
You're just like him.
Wait, wait, wait.
Fudge Shop, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, don't give us birthday today.
Haven't chosen a cake yet, so I'm asking you to pick a flavor.
The wilder, the better since I've had sushi cake last year.
Get green tea.
Green tea cake.
Also, happy birthday Fudge!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Fudge.
Yeah!
Or ice cream.
No, ice cream cake!
Get ice cream cake!
Ice cream cake is so much better!
Yowza!
That's what I'm talking about!
Not so deadpo- Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yup.
I can't believe it.
He's in my chat too.
Oh my god.
Can we get a jump bot for ourselves?
If we clobber them?
If you clobber them, then fine.
Sure.
Don't thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not even a true simp.
Didn't ask for feedback.
You should sound confident.
The entrance to the ship is through the cave up ahead.
Okay.
We gotta go through there.
I imagine that bouncing schmucks already made it pretty far inside.
Go get him.
What?
By the way, miss.
Could you say that again just one more time?
Oh my god.
He's hooked, guys.
He's hooked.
Afraid not.
That was a limited time offer.
He's gonna tier 10 sub to her.
Oh my god.
It's too late.
He's gonna find out what's her YouTube account.
She's gonna be his Oshi forever now.
Alright.
Well, okay.
How far is this?
Okay.
190.
I'm gonna grab this.
Grab these items.
And then we'll go back and steal that dinosaur.
I'm gonna GTD it.
Okay.
Grab this.
And then...
Alright.
I'm full HP now.
Does that heal my tank as well?
Does drinking water heal my tank?
Can I select...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I'm going back.
It's time to GTD it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Damn.
This just got me thinking about how people...
About people donate for a...
Yeah.
That line.
That line, right?
You know the deal.
The deal clock.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
JP, thank you for the super chat.
He's gonna find her only tanks.
No!
I can't GT.
Bro, what the fuck?
No dino...
No!
And then he ran off!
No dinos allowed.
Sir!
This is Dino-sist!
Me, thank you for the...
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
They hate dinosaurs!
It's time.
It's time to get rid of a...
Get rid of a village.
Oh my god.
He's the chosen one.
Is that so?
Just you wait.
I'm gonna be the biggest, baddest demon ever.
Let's see.
Oh, they're fine.
They're fine, guys.
Battle ship cape.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's loot.
Can I like, loot it from here?
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
I don't have to get off my tank.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
It's not a crime.
If they deserve it.
They...
They scared my... They wouldn't let me have my dinos!
This cave is huge!
Looks like this cave leads straight to the Lysa battleship.
Wait, is that the part?
It seems that the Junkers have cobbled together a convenient route between the market and battleship.
Oh, here it is.
There it is.
But how do I...
No dino for you.
That's not...
That's so fucked up.
Oh, I have to jump.
I have to parkour.
Guys, I found the yellow.
I found the fucking yellow.
It's always the yellow.
Alright, this way.
This way.
I like how like, the sound is...
I like the sound design for this game.
Like, even in the caves, you can tell like...
We're in the caves with the immersion.
Find all sorts of treasure hidden around the world.
Use these skills.
Thief Raider to make locating treasure easier.
But...
I don't...
Thief?
Treasure?
Spood Booster Chip.
Oh, I found like a booster chip.
Oh, that's nice.
Roku, thank you for the gift of chips.
Thank you.
The yellow paint cave.
My favorite.
My favorite type of cave.
I don't need ladders.
I can parkour.
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, this has to be...
Okay, this is the lore.
So, maybe there's loot here?
I knew it.
I'm a real gamer, guys.
Welcome to level design.
Here we go.
Alright.
Let's see.
Loot.
Yay!
Alright.
Looks like we can head inside.
Let me in.
Okay, he didn't stop me.
Okay, I was gonna say, let me in right now.
And he's like, okay.
He's like, it was never locked.
Doki, it was never locked.
You go right in.
Go right in.
Oh!
Okay, that's pretty.
It's so beautiful.
Let me send a tank in.
Time to destroy it all with a tank.
It's so beautiful.
Oh!
Even the music's nice, though.
Oh, I love the BGM for this.
Looks like we've hit a dead end.
Oh, there has to be a boss fight in the sand.
Blast from the main cannon should blow it all away.
Nice.
We're gonna destroy...
a world wonder.
Yeah, I'm inside the ship.
Oh!
What's this?
Yes, that's the way.
No!
He's too thick!
Guys, close the door!
Guys, I need you guys to close the door!
Bro, I don't know, guys.
I think...
I think my allies are a bit stupid.
Okay, what if I do this and I turn around?
And it's magic!
It's a magic trick.
Guys, you guys like my magic trick?
The door is stuck.
Literally all they had to do was just close the door.
That's all they...
Wait, can I...
Oh, they have invisible walls for a reason.
They Doki-proofed it.
They did not Doki-proof it.
Hahaha!
Alright.
We got...
more B-grade stuff.
I assume like...
Okay, there must be loot around here.
Right?
Because we have to go to the top.
So there must be hidden loot right here.
Judging by my gamer skills.
There must... Okay.
Just not here apparently.
I guess not here.
Alright.
Yellow!
Thank god for the yellow.
So I make sure...
I mean, there has to be loot arou- Oh fuck, okay.
What the fuck?
Did I actually use my double jump?
There should be loot right here, right?
Cause like look, there's this.
If I jump on this platform...
and then here...
No!
What?
What the fuck?
Guys, you just...
guys watched me jump like that?
You're not gonna help out?
Surely, right?
Like, huh?
Oh, there's like...
What?
I can't stand on the pipes?
But what?
Hahaha!
That's fucked up, yo.
They wouldn't let me stand on the pipes, guys.
No floor.
Okay, this way.
What the heck happened here?
The place is a mess.
Hahaha!
Trying for the scale would do that.
Try to watch your footing.
Thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Shit, I just got paid anyway.
Can I get it?
You're my little pogchamp.
Come here.
Hahaha!
Thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow!
I keep falling!
That's why I told you to watch your...
Wait.
Someone's coming.
What?
Who is it?
Oh, there it is.
There's the...
pause button.
Alright.
It's time to grab the tank.
Give me a sec.
Pause, pause, guys!
Pause!
Hahaha!
There you go.
Thank you for all grouping up together.
Nice.
Reloading?
Is that it?
Oh, that was easy.
Oh my god!
He said bot!
Sorry, I thought...
Hahaha!
Bro, that sounded like dumb fuck.
I was like...
Hahaha!
Did not sound like that!
I was like...
Oh my god!
He is a demon!
We gotta go this way.
Alright.
Nice.
We got a battleship.
One obtained.
Oh, we got a map of this.
I thought I already had the map of it.
I guess we have a map of it here.
Here?
Is that me?
Alright.
I'm gonna beat you up.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna beat you up with my fists!
Oh, I doubled up!
Yeah!
Alright.
Performing leg sweep.
Allows you to evade mid jump.
Focuses your energy.
Releasing will let you...
Okay, I think I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do an air combo.
Let's see.
The rare moments I get to fight.
I feel like...
We'll do air combo.
I feel like air combo will be better.
Alright.
And then...
Let's see.
Poison gas.
Item picker.
Destroy nearby rocks and collect all available.
The enemy has gifted a bomb.
Oh, okay.
You're gonna start collecting stuff.
That's good.
That's actually more helpful than whatever the fuck the sheriff is doing.
Where are...
Hey, guys.
I have a feeling one of them is more helpful than the other.
I knew the interior was so huge!
Case in point.
We can jump.
Oh, there's items here.
We got one of the steers.
Oh my god, there were stairs this whole time?
Sorry.
That was a close call.
Oh hey, there's a dead guy.
Red dude?
Who the fuck is the red dude?
Is it the... the...
Oh wait, what the fuck?
It's the Royal Army?
Guys, the girl doesn't need upgrades.
She's already perfect.
She's just there to upgrade my tank.
It's mine.
Doki, he's old!
Give him some slack!
Tank time.
Tank time!
Boom.
Boom!
Guys, is this overkill?
No.
Nothing has ever...
What is this gonna do?
Explode?
Oh shit!
Guys...
I think it exploded, guys.
Oh wait, there's stuff here.
Guys, wanna see my trick?
Watch this.
Abracadabra.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Guys, watch this.
Abracadabra.
Pretty sure I could get over that with a hijack.
Sorry, there was a delay.
Guys, sorry.
My magic trick was lagging, guys.
Guys, it's understandable, okay?
My magic trick was lagging, okay?
There's like... I'm on a... I'm on an East Coast server at the moment, so it lagged a little.
What's this?
Open.
Open sesame.
Oh, I definitely need the tank.
They're not locked in here.
I'm not locked in here with them.
I'm locked... They're locked in here with me.
Say less.
Oh hey, they can jump too.
What the fuck?
Am I not special?
The door is unlocked!
Yeah!
No one keeps Biel's prisoner.
On we go!
Which way?
This way?
You might get locked inside again.
Stay alert.
Yeah!
Where do I go?
What's this?
Yeah, what's this?
That switch probably controls this elevator.
Where?
Try turning it on.
Wait, where?
Oh, here.
Can I turn it on in my tank?
No, I have to get off the tank.
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna get off the railing.
What?
No.
Where's the switch?
Oh my god.
What?
Bro, get up there.
Excuse me?
Goodbye.
Hello?
Excuse me?
Wow...
It's up here?
Is this...
How the fuck... OK Guys, the elevator was the floor all along guys.
Guys, the elevator was the floor.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
There was a switch next to the elevator!
What?
Alright, here we go.
Wrong one.
There we go.
Is there another fight here?
No.
I just have to go forward.
I like how the...
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay, there we go.
We're fine.
This is not overkill.
Let's reload this real fast too.
Awww.
Where's the arm?
Oh, this is the arm.
Boom.
Alright, we gotta get off.
Here.
Alright, up we go!
Here we go!
And up here.
Up here.
Yeah!
Wait, there's a yellow.
Guys, there's a yellow door.
And we know what that means.
Thank God for all the yellow.
There's another yellow door.
There's a secret here.
There's a secret!
Have I been here?
Oh my God, there's a secret!
Look at all the yellow doors!
Not a good place to call it.
Okay, don't worry.
Woo!
Oop!
Look at all these yellow doors!
Whoops, wrong one.
Sorry.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay, and then reload.
Oh, I got you!
Oh God, how did I miss?
How did I miss?
There you go.
Oh my God.
Look at all these yellow doors for me.
I'm so far away from the objective.
Wait, the yellow stopped.
Is the yellow here?
Oh, there's the yellow light!
There's the yellow light!
Where's the loot?
Where is it?
Oh, there...
Oh!
Woo!
Don't worry, my ship is okay.
There you go.
Okay, we gotta grab the mats though.
Mats time!
Assimilate.
Alright.
Where are...
Don't worry, my tank is okay.
Guys, my tank will be okay.
Where the fuck is the loot?
What did I get?
You have acquired an option module.
It has various effects.
Use them to gain advantage in battles.
There are special parts that cannot be crafted or upgraded on their own.
The effects grow together with the vehicle's level.
Activate using LB.
After using an active effect, you must wait for the cooldown.
Oh!
Prince, I can't lend you a hand right now.
Wait, I have to activate my...
Oh my god.
I thought he was already doing that for me.
Alright, guys.
Is there any doors back here?
Just in case.
Alright, no doors.
Alright.
So I can customize my vehicle.
Where is it?
Is it this?
Automatic fires.
Oh, automatic fires.
Okay, guys.
Guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Is it this?
That's so cool.
Activated it.
Alright, we gotta go back.
Okay, I think I gotta heal my tank a little bit.
Just a...
Just a maybe.
Um...
Just...
Just a maybe.
How do I...
Okay, restore...
There we go.
Alright.
We did it.
Good.
There came a point where like...
I was like...
There was maybe a little bit too much...
A little bit too much glow-y.
Wait, have I been through there?
Wait, there's another yellow door.
Is this where I came from?
Oh, this is where I came from.
Wait, there's a level 16?
Guys, I think I can take him.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I think I can take him.
Watch this.
Guys, watch this.
You know why I know?
Because he can come in through here.
Guys, watch this.
There's no way.
Watch, guys.
I can take him.
Guys, what is he gonna do?
Go through that door?
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do about it?
That's right.
Oh, he went through the door!
Guys, guys, he went through the door!
He was not too thick!
I thought he'd be too thick, guys!
Guys!
He was not too thick!
He was not thick!
He was appropriately sized!
That's okay.
He's so far from me.
It's okay.
The ricochet from this.
He's too far.
We did it.
I knew we could do it.
Guys, look at that.
I get 7 XP for that?
That's a bullshit!
Oh my god!
That's actually bullshit!
I can't believe I only get like 7 XP.
I can't believe it.
That was a bounty, right?
That had to be a bounty.
But the loot token...
But how am I gonna level up?
It's all about the levels.
Think, chat.
Think.
That was not worth it.
Wow!
I thought I died from that.
How did I get there?
Okay, this way.
This way.
And now walk over from here.
And then... Yeah!
Oh!
Here we go!
Okay, now!
Yay!
Okay, we're through the door.
Hello!
Okay, this is like...
Wait, can I...
Prince, I can't lend you a hand right now.
No, help me!
Help me loot!
There's so much loot here!
Wait, where am I?
There has to be...
There's a level 5 thug here!
Let's beat him up!
That's fucking right.
Give me your lunch money.
Wait, am I supposed...
Oh, hey!
Nice!
Hey, little chip!
Yeah!
Alright, we go here.
Okay, guys.
Guys, guys, guys!
Pause, pause!
Pause, guys!
Guys, pause!
Pause!
Thank you for waiting.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god!
Holy shit, that actually hurt!
At least they waited though.
And then we go this way.
Loot!
Yay!
Is there loot here?
Loot, loot, loot!
No!
Guys, close the door!
Don't you hate it when the homies don't close the door?
Abra...
Cadabra.
Magic.
Wait, what?
Oh, there it is.
I was like... I swore I saw like glowing stuff.
Yay!
Heavy gallon gun.
What's that?
A trap?
There's no traps here.
Get over here.
Fight me at my level.
There you go.
Yeah!
That's the worst trap ever.
Tango and Super Waifu, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, we go up.
Let's see.
Okay, that is where the actual thing is.
There's no loot here, so we'll go this way.
Alright, hello guys!
Hello!
That's fucking right.
Get down.
Fight me at my level!
Ooh, that's a big boy.
Yellow!
Loot, loot, loot, loot, loot!
There's loot here.
Where's the yellow?
You can't just bait me with the yellow and then disappear like that.
There it is!
Loot.
He's just a little guy.
Yeah, he is.
Okay, parkour.
There's more over there.
Nice.
And that's how you parkour.
I'm a gamer.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
I think that was everything.
Yeah, you fail.
You have to do the walk of shame.
Not me.
Boop!
Thank god for the yellow lights.
I'm so glad they thought of everything.
Can I just run past it?
Oh no, I can't.
It's okay.
I've killed your dad.
You're nothing!
Boop!
Oh my god, he did so much damage!
Okay, maybe he is something.
There you go.
Alright.
Guys, there is a possibility that he is something.
Oh, this looks like a boss room.
100%.
Eh, I guess not.
Not really, actually.
It's just two guys.
What are two guys gonna do?
Boop!
Wait, I missed?
There you go.
At least that was sort of fun.
Yay!
I have so much mats right now.
I have not used a single...
I just noticed I have so much mats but I have not actually used anything.
Oh, I... Oh, loot.
Okay.
I haven't upgraded anything on my tank.
I wasn't allowed to!
There was nothing to upgrade!
I swear!
There was nothing to upgrade at all!
If there was, I would have upgraded like years ago.
Alright, grab this.
There you go.
Oh, wait.
Did I miss?
No.
It just moved.
There you go.
Yay!
I can't believe I can't fucking blast those boxes open.
This place is practically falling apart!
I just didn't get the loot.
Flo and Steady?
Oh, wait.
That's an abyss.
Let's proceed with care.
Weeeee!
I'm gonna keep running.
Loot!
Where?
Where is it?
Here we go.
Let's blow up.
Uh...
Oh my god, where is it?
Where is it?
They can't bait me like this!
Okay.
I need to be a loot goblin!
Okay, we got...
Nope.
Guys, I think my tank will be okay.
And then here...
Is that all of them?
That should be all of them.
I see it!
I see the glowing box!
Guys.
Oh.
Here we go.
I have to get it.
I see something shiny.
And I must have it.
Bro, I ain't afraid of you.
You gotta chase me down first if you wanna do anything.
Here we go.
Boop.
Oh!
Whoa!
Ow!
Don't make me mad!
Don't make me angry!
I'm coming over here!
That's fucking right!
I'll spare you!
Tell your friends!
Wait.
Guys, pause.
Pause.
I need to upgrade my stuff.
Uh...
Wait!
The damage sucks!
What the fuck?
It's not even bigger da- Oh, wait.
No, that's not even bigger damage.
The damage sucks!
This damage is terrible!
I lied too.
Okay, this way.
More ammo.
I don't need ammo!
I'm all in on the damage!
Zero defense, full damage.
If I kill them first, then like, I won't get hurt.
I won't get hit.
Alright, this way.
Woah.
Woah, we went 2D here.
What?
Woah!
Oh my god!
Wait, but how do I...
AHHHH!
I didn't expect it.
I did not expect the 2D part.
We went 2D, 3D.
Now it's a real platformer.
Yeah.
I know there was loot back here.
Huh!
Yep.
Nothing gonna do.
Nothing.
It's just gonna explode anyway.
Yay!
It's Crash Bandicoot time.
Yeah!
I was like, what the fuck?
It just came out of nowhere.
Yay!
Tank time.
Go tank, go!
Nice.
Goodbye.
I need a platform for my tank.
Yay!
No one expects the 2D Inquisition.
Is that... It's a jumper!
Is that the jumper?
Oh my god, is that mine?
Oh my god, he looks so cool!
I'm done playing with you now.
He's cooler because there is more color on it.
It looks so 2D...I love the texture on that model chat.
I feel like the texture on this 3D model looks a little It looks 2D.
That's actually insane.
I can't pretend I didn't just hear that pinch-squeak!
Hmm..
Your budget ran out for this scene.
I'm not allowed to play more than one hour of video games though apparently.
Look they ran out of money!
They had me do the long chair.
Who paid that much?
We're here on a job to deal with that jump bot from a junkers market resident.
Can't we just work out a peaceful solution?
No!
Peaceful?
Does he look like peaceful?
What?
You not used to seeing girls either?
Nah, what I'm interested in is your necklace.
Necklace?
Better close it.
I could get a damn good price for it.
I'll take that as payment.
No way!
I'll never give this up no matter what!
Yeah!
No!
Too bad!
When I see something I want, I ain't in the habit of letting it go.
What?
What the fuck?
Where did he- what?
He's so fast!
Oh wait!
It's a different person!
I was like- whoa!
Give it back!
That necklace means everything to me!
Stand back, Anne.
It's my turn to repay you.
For what?
Yeah, for what?
I mean, same.
Even you're no match for my jump bot, demon boy!
Holy shit!
There's missiles on that jump bot!
Oh god!
Guys, guys!
Remember I said I don't need heals?
Okay!
I'm gonna repair my- I realized that I might need a re- Wait, wait, wait.
Interception!
Do your thing!
Intercept!
Oh no, I have to reload.
I didn't go into the fight- I didn't reload while- Guys!
Guys, I made the most fatal mistake!
I didn't reload!
Shoot him down with the machine!
What?
Oh, the- Not reloading before the fight, guys.
I- I made- I made the most common mistake.
Time to get crazy!
Oh no, he's gonna get crazy, guys.
He's gonna jump so fucking crazy!
Where am I looking at?
What is that?
Oh.
I have to play my ace in the hole!
What?
This?
Oh!
Stop, you prince!
Get ready to dodge!
What?
Guys, I did it!
Ah, crap!
Okay, I'm fucking putting on autopilot.
Oh shit, no!
That autopilot was a mistake, guys!
Oh!
Good job, prince!
Oh my god, controller aiming.
Nitro!
Okay.
Nice, we're fine.
We're halfway through!
Come on!
Critical-
Alright, I hear you.
Oh, I can shoot him while he's just standing there.
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank god I could just, like, you know, stab.
Wait, can I shoot him out of the air?
Thank god, he just stands there menacingly.
Oh!
Come on.
Just stay still!
Just a little more, prince!
He's gonna blow up!
Oh no.
I didn't miss, guys.
That was a hit.
Okay, and then...
Oh my god, he's only...
He's 1 HP!
Goodbye!
Yes!
Here.
Thank you, BLs.
What did you mean...
What happened to the other person?
Huh?
Yeah, what did I...
What did...
What did she do?
Oh, the bullet!
You must be the time you took a bullet for him.
I remember!
It's the bullet!
You know, BLs, you're a pretty stand-up guy.
Stop before I puke!
Not to bring down the mood, but you did a real number on the bot, BLs.
No!
My new toy!
Hmm... Nah.
I think we can work with this.
Oh, thank god.
All those items I hoarded, finally, it's gonna be used for something.
The Warframe is still intact.
I can figure out the rest somehow or other.
Let's get back to Spino and rebuild this thing then!
Let this be a lesson to you, to change your ways...
Yeah!
Evil doesn't pay!
There can only be one evil person in the world.
Lesson learned!
Don't encroach on my territory!
Level up!
Yay!
Okay, what can I get?
Raise his power, perform a leg sweep.
A leg sweep, boost power of B attacks, hold...
Ooh!
Okay, wait, I wanna...
Boost power of X attacks.
Uh...
You know what?
I wanna boost power of X attacks later.
I feel like that's the best one for upgrades.
Uh...
I feel like... am I gonna get more allies?
Cause there's three...
There's three...
Like silhouettes at the top.
So does that mean I'm gonna have more allies later?
Let's get this...
Okay, do I care?
Duration of...
Increases duration of vehicle warfare when he draws hostile vehicles towards his tank.
Temporary increase...
Oh!
What?
Wait, you have your own tank?
Okay.
Help.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
I didn't realize he has his own tank.
I was afraid I'd blown my chance at riding a jump buck for a second.
Prince, you need to learn to control yourself.
Try and thank him for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, super sticker.
Wait, now you mean.
We got what we came for, right?
Oh, wait, there's items here.
Nice.
But I was hoping we'd have more time to hunt for parts.
The wannabe junkers may be gone, but the defenders are still around.
So don't even think about coming in here alone.
I know, I know.
I'd never be that reckless.
Probably.
All right, time to leave.
Time to go back to back home.
Move.
All right, time to leave.
Yay!
Wait, have I?
Oh, I've been here.
I've been here before.
Okay.
All I have to do is just jump down.
Yay!
And then it should be here, right?
Can I just fast travel?
What's this?
Yeah.
Oh my God, I can just fast travel.
Thank God.
I was like, I am not walking back there.
What's wrong?
Aren't you going in?
Yeah, what's going on?
I am.
It's just there's an urgent news bulletin on the radio now.
Oh, okay.
Cause this is so fast that there's no fall damage.
I'm a demon too.
Okay.
Yesterday, a Royal Army tank was hijacked from that base by unknown saboteurs.
The perpetrators have got on a rampage with their stolen tank, looting vital water supplies and destroying several towns.
What?
What the...?
What is going on?
This is not suspicious, guys.
I know they're asking for like...
Our tank is number tank 42.
30 million!
Bro, I'm just gonna turn myself in.
Guys, why don't we just cross out the 4 and break 105?
I mean, Mayor Tor trusts you guys, so...
Damn it.
How could the Royal Army sink so low?
Bro, just rewrite this...
Get fucking paint and rewrite the name!
We'll have to spend the rest of our lives on the run.
Oh my god.
Guys, we can like get paint!
30 million is 30...
True.
Like I said, I turned myself in.
I went the wrong way.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why am I leaving?
30 million is 30 million, guys.
Come on.
You turn me in if it was 30 million.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Strength serum...
Wait, where's my home?
There's like ceiling lights, army base...
What will I do with 50 chairs?
What?
Did I rob the base?
Like...
Here, thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you.
Bro, I get 50 windows.
50 consoles.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck am I gonna do with all these items?
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Let's see.
Apparently, I robbed something.
Alright, parts.
Upgrade part.
I can upgrade.
Yay.
Which one is the one that I equipped though?
Is it the green?
I can't tell.
Customized vehicle.
Oh, wait.
It is.
Okay, it's the green.
Okay.
That has 97 damage.
24.
Wait.
What is this?
What's the...
Oh, attack interval.
Well, it's uncommon so it should be better.
Right?
Let's see.
Upgrade.
Oh, this is the one I equipped.
Okay.
I'm gonna upgrade this.
Might as well.
Yay!
I mean, I have so much money.
I might as well.
You know?
Okay.
Upgrade.
Nice.
Senita, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't afford 30 minutes but here's my part to turn yourself in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I can upgrade my vehicle.
Oh, wait.
Might as well.
You know?
Oh, okay.
We gotta get chip slot, guys.
Okay.
And then...
Get that level 2.
And get that level 3.
And I might as well get that level 4.
Wait, how much can I do?
Oh, okay.
Level 5.
Just fall in.
God, my tank is so tanky now.
Okay, I only have one.
You're clear.
Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you call an old snowman?
A glass of water.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
I can finally add a chip.
Okay, power chip.
Quick reload.
Power plus chip.
Okay, we gotta get the cannon.
The cannon has been like the life saver.
Alright, nice.
How do I decorate my village?
Our only hope is to find that spring as soon as we can.
Let's abandon the tank and forget all about this.
We got lucky.
They still don't know who we really are.
Some demon you are, thief.
Don't be such a coward.
But, Prince...
I'll keep looking for the spring all on my own if I have to.
Look, you chose this guy to join us.
We could have got the cool centaur.
I'll come too.
We're basically partners in crime.
I wanted a centaur.
Let me be clear.
I'm not turning back until I've seen that spring with my own eyes.
If you can't handle that, then go home already.
But...
What will everyone say if they see me return without you?
Don't be a worrywart, Grams.
I'm sure things will work out.
Once the jump bot's ready, I just know we'll find the spring.
How can you be so sure?
You're a gutsy one, aren't you?
Oh, what?
We're out of town now?
Where's our... where's the woman?
Can Anne find working on that jump bot all on her own?
We just... exactly!
I spent all my money upgrading the tank and now they want to abandon it?
What the fuck?
We're better off getting some rest for the journey ahead.
We're going to be aimlessly wandering through the southern desert with an entire army on our tail.
Don't worry.
I lived in the south thirty years ago.
So I at least know the general lay of the land there.
Ah.
Thirty years ago?
You mean back when the Peechee still inhabited the area?
Oh, back when the aliens...
That would be about the time the royal army wiped them all out.
He was part of the massacre!
He's a bad old person!
We need to push him.
Such a tragedy.
That made my list of the top ten most foolish things...
Wait, what's number one?
...humanity has ever done?
Foolish.
But it prevented the Peechee from destroying all of Sandland with their doomsday weapon.
That a doomsday weapon?
Really?
You actually believe that?
Aster, thank you for the magenta soup pot!
Thank you!
Hey Doki, I've been loving the streams I've been able to catch.
Also super excited for the rob the bank merch to ship.
Thank you!
We might be able to ship it beginning of next month.
So I'm super excited.
Peechee, we're really developing a machine that makes water.
Oh my god!
He got influenced by propaganda!
He got propagandized!
What?
Water?
No, that can't be true.
Oh my god!
Are Peechee's like the Piccolo's in this universe?
It's true alright.
The brilliant Peechee...
I forgot the name of their species.
The something.
It starts with an N, right?
Not just for themselves but to share with everyone.
That's a Deadpool!
Thank you for the farm!
Get the chips!
Thank you!
Get the... Namikil... Namik... Namik... N... N... N... something.
Namikil...
Because the Royal Army's profits would go up in smoke if that happened.
They got rid of the Peechee first.
The massive explosion that happened when they were attacked was caused by the aquarium they needed to make their machine work.
Which the Royal Army gave them knowing what would happen.
And the Royal Army used a massive aquarium bomb to wipe out every last one of them.
No... but...
This is when he realized how badly he fucked up.
Before then he was like, okay I was just doing my orders and it can't be that bad.
Now he realized everything he did.
He doomed humanity.
The commander of the tank brigade that attacked them.
Who ordered the shots that set off the aquarium.
Was it you, Sheriff?
It was you, wasn't it?
It was me.
I knew it!
Okay, we like sort of called this in like...
We literally... we're like, bro, he obviously used to be from the army.
Resulting explosion.
Destroyed almost my entire village.
And everyone in my whole brigade, apart from me, was killed in an instant.
Guys, I wrote this game.
I ghost wrote this game, guys.
They made us attack.
Now he has more trauma.
That explosion.
Wait.
If they knew, why would they make your tanks attack inside the blast radius?
Bro, stop spoiling the game, dokey.
Our brigade never much like supreme commanders.
They use methods.
We spoke our minds too much.
Oh, well, not your fault, huh?
You had no idea.
He still killed people.
He still... bro, he literally wiped out an entire race.
You can't just be like, he was just following orders.
He knew what... he still... the context of wiping the entire race just changed.
He still did it.
Like...
Like, he still... like, it just changed the context of him wiping... the reasoning why he wiped the entire race.
But then...
The P.G.
were really developing a machine that made water.
The real fiend here...
It's you.
And the royal army...
Wait, he murders!
A massive...
He actually murders!
...the very last one of them.
Bro!
The demons can't even kill, but he can!
It's actually me.
Hm?
What the fuck is he doing?
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna turn into a giant monkey right now.
Sorry, wrong... wrong manga.
What in the world?
The Toriyama...
I'm absorbing the power of death.
...cinematic universe.
Because it looks... like we're in for a fight.
Guys, my game crashed.
Okay, I think that's a good time to call it.
Okay, I'm gonna call it here.
I mean, we had a lot...
We played for...
We played for four hours.
Did it save?
Well, it has auto-save, so I think we'll be fine.
Honestly, I've been enjoying it so far.
I don't know...
Let's see how long this game is.
Let me see.
Sun...
Land...
Earth...
How long is the game?
Let me look it up.
How long is Sand Land?
It took me 32 hours to finish Sand Land!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um...
I'll think about it.
25 hours...
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna think about it, guys.
I'm not gonna give you guys any promises.
If there's a cut to...
If there's a part two, there's a part two.
If you never see a part two again, you know what I mean.
Okay.
I'll think about it, guys.
I'm gonna think about it, chat.
Well...
We'll...
I had fun, though.
I had a lot of fun, though, chat.
This has been, like, pretty enjoyable.
Like, the action RPG part.
Um...
But, I'll definitely think about it, guys, if we'll do a part two.
But I definitely enjoy it a lot so far.
So far, um, what's the spon- no, no, it wasn't sponsored.
I just really want to check it out on launch after, like, uh, it was like, um, you know, post- I can't, I can't, I don't want to- I don't want to- post-humously released after Tori- you know, after Toriyama- what happened to Toriyama.
And I really want to check it out because I talked about this before, but I grew up- my- my uncle was a huge Toriyama fan.
And, like, he owned, like, a lot- like, everything.
He owned, like, all his manga.
Like, all the manga that he ever wrote.
And, like, uh, I think, like, one of my- I remember- I remember one of my favorite one-shots that he did was, uh, I think it's called Kajika.
And, like, he owned everything.
And then, uh, like, it wasn't just, like, Dragon Ball Z or Dragon Ball or, like, Dr. Sub.
Every single one-shot that was published, um, my uncle owned- owned all of them.
Um, and I would, like, hang out in his room reading all the manga- like, all of his manga and stuff.
And I thought, like, oh, I really wanted to, you know- I, uh, really wanted to, um, check out this game as, like, uh, you know, like, uh- because I never really played, uh, uh, I guess, like, a Toriyama game on PC before.
Um, the last time I played a game based off of any of Toriyama's works was- um, the Dragon Ball Z game on the Game Boy Advance.
And that was, like, the only time I've ever played a, uh, one of his, uh, one of his, like, works being adapted into a video game.
I never even, like, played any of, like, the, you know, like, the Dragon Ball Z, like, fighter games.
I never played any of those on PC.
So, I figured, like, oh, you know, it's a good time to check it out.
Uh, and it- I- it was pretty enjoyable so far.
I've had a great time checking out- uh, checking out Sand Land.
It was really cool that Bandai dropped by.
I- I was like, oh my god!
They noticed me!
Guys!
Bandai noticed me!
Dragon Qu- guys, of course I haven't played Dragon Quest.
I told you about me and JRPGs, guys.
I- I am- I usually- I am not, like- like, JRPGs are not my preference.
That's why when I saw Action JRPG, I was like, oh, I'm not gonna play that.
I was like, oh my god, I like Action.
I- I like Action.
So, um, I was like, that's for me.
So that's why I was like, okay, I'll check it out just because it's Action.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna call it here.
Tomorrow's a rest day.
And then Saturday's sort of like a rest day because there's only, like, the- it's like Goodnight Dragoons on Saturday.
And, uh, but I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream, everybody.
I always have great time streaming for you guys.
As always.
I'm JRPG.
I'll see you guys next time.
Bye!
Everyone stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Oh
my god!
Secret ending!
I just got an email from- from one of the represent- bandai.
They want to send me a collector's edition of Sadland.
Guys, I'm getting free shit!
Okay, we're gonna do a part two.
Sadland.
They're like, thank you for streaming Sadland!
We will send you a collector- okay, we're good.
I guess I have to do a part two now.
Anyway, guys.
Bye for real.
Sorry, wrong screen.
I got so excited.